the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
to day one of the 2022 us chess
championships and U.S women's chess
Championships held here at the St Louis
chess club it's going to be a fantastic
three weeks of exciting chess let's go
to the studio and start the action with
Yasser and Anastasia
welcome to Saint Louis the capital of
U.S chess and the host of USGS open and
women's championships from the famous St
Louis chess club we are ready to call
all the action
thank you
I'm woman Grand Master Anastasia
carlowicz and I'm with my brilliant
co-host Grandmaster Yasir sarova
brilliant
welcome back it's so lovely to have you
in studio thank you so much for coming
thank you Yasser it's an honor to be
here with you always oh wonderful hello
everyone uh Welcome to our show thank
you for sharing your day and joining us
this year's U.S Championship is a kind
of a catch-up for the whole pandemic so
the fields have been expanded there are
14 players in both events the women's
and the open let's take a look at our
competitors in the women's event because
it is very strong indeed Anastasia we
have a lot of U.S Champions at the top
Arena Crush eight times yes
I'm gonna leave it there big of uh are
our favorites but as you look all the
way down another U.S Champion Jennifer
you yes exactly she became the champion
in 2020 if I'm not mistaken and Sabina
fuser uh 13th seed also a U.S champion
and in the open we don't have
many of us Champions but we've got a lot
of 2700s Wesley so our defending
Champion Levon aronian aw for Lavon
welcome welcome Fabi Lanier Sam Shanklin
Ray Robson Jeffrey Jean are our top half
Hans Neiman Sam Seville on some
incredible mix of veterans and uh
Juniors and there he is our defending
Champion has arrived Wesley so actually
yes the current rule a U.S champion and
yes sir if I can mention this we have
three U.S Champions playing in the
tournament and we also have the fourth
one season next to me yes sir let's not
forget you were the US champion too I
won four of the titles uh steinens was
ineligible and let's take a look at our
format for these two events yeah we have
14 play around Robin event 90 minutes
they have for the first 40 moves right
and then 30 minutes for the rest of the
game 30 seconds increment from one and
of course no draw offers everybody
fights Until the End absolutely in our
schedule
let's check the schedule as well so we
have 13 Rounds starting from today
October 5th and then actually we have
direct tourist days the October 10th and
also a second one on 16th of October and
we have playoffs if we need them
outstanding and as always we're very
fortunate to have it Studio our dear
friend Christian good to see you my
friend good to see you guys great to be
back and I see Anastasia and Yasser in
the casting Booth as well we have 28 of
the best chess players here on American
soil battling out for who's going to be
the next U.S champion and U.S woman
champion and let's take a look at
players that I have my eyes on in this
event and we're going to start with the
ladies section one player in particular
that I'm definitely going to follow it's
woman Grand Master Jennifer you only 20
years of age or sophomore right now in
college Invitational rating 22 97 she's
also she's very accustomed to winning
big events she won in 2019 the U.S
Women's Championship with a dominating
performance 10 out of 11 possible points
just an incredible performance also
she's the reigning Undisputed U.S girls
junior champion and I'm definitely going
to be following her lead in this one and
let's take a look at the open section as
well we have one Jeffrey Sean this is
the player that in my opinion is a
potential dark horse to win this event
only 21 years of age but he's been
around the elite level players for a
very long time we've seen him in the US
chess championships for so many years I
think this will be his year Invitational
rating 2690 he is the 2016 US Junior
chess champion and the 2016 World Junior
Champion just an incredible player and
I'm definitely looking forward to see
what he's going to be bringing to the
table but I mean we have 28 of the best
chess players in the United States
battling for who will be the best for
the next three weeks it's just
incredible and there we see Christian as
the players are gathering in the playing
Hall they get one that we have taken
some extra security measures including a
delay of our broadcast as we see begum
getting wanted and do the honor set the
table for us what are the pairings for
the ladies for this round one as we get
set to get underway
let's check round one pairing so we have
one skip playing against Jennifer you
that places against Divina Crush I gotta
stop you right there those twos that's a
great start those are two amazing
matchups for the ladies sorry please do
continue yes exactly and then Sabina for
for sure plays against Nazi paigija who
was also the U.S women's of champion two
times if I'm not mistaken then we have
Megan Lee who plays against Rochelle and
then a cheater
right right and then beg him who we just
saw at the screen she plays against uh
Sofia yes Talia versus and in the open
sections and the open section also we
have really nice pairings right for
today Alexander Linderman plays against
Lebon aronian and then also I paid
attention to Fabiano who plays against
linear Dominguez this is gonna be a
really big fight I guess and Marquee
matchups for sure sampling against
elshon elshon of course qualified as the
U.S Open winner yes and then I wonder
young plays against the current champion
Wesley Seoul Christopher you plays
against hanseniman Jeff fiction gets the
dairy sweets and then also one of the US
Champions Sam Shanklin plays against Ray
Robson two great
Olympians in fact yes and what will they
be fighting for over these next three
weeks in terms of money tell us about
the ladies money very very impressive uh
price fund for ladies event 160 and 500
dollars every dollar counts right and
then let's say first place is 40 000
very impressive and even though those
who will be the last really decent
prices thirteen thousand five hundred
and three thousand for players 13 to 14
and in the open section what is the
prize fund there
and also another impressive fund 262
000 wow dollars yes and now I think it's
time to get back to the plane hole
absolutely Tony Rich will uh give the
final instructions as the round one is
getting ready to get underway
waiting for that switch but yes I think
we're gonna go wake up the production
team hi we're here in the playing Hall
with all am I going sorry we're here in
the playing Hall with everyone uh
they're settling in as they're going
through their security checks uh filling
in their score sheets and shaking hands
with their opponents everybody's serious
and ready to play chess today and I'm
sure we'll we'll see all the excitement
across the board back to you guys
well thank you very much Tony for that I
uh I understand
that the players have to check in all of
their Electronics then they get wanted
and the procedure for 28 people can be a
little bit of a a jam you get in line
right Christian no absolutely and again
we have 28 players guys so if you come
with only 10 minutes before the round
and you have like a 10 uh player
potential line waiting to be wanted uh
and every single time you get wanted is
probably going to take at least one
minute we see how thorough Christopher
the Arbiter of this event is with that
new and improved one so definitely you
have to be careful as a player you also
get penalized if you are a late to your
game you will be fine 500
small money exactly so it's something
like when I was playing if you were late
one hour late you lost the game but if
you were 50 minutes late well there was
no penalties or anything like that then
the fide went the other way Zero
Tolerance you you weren't at the board
when they hit the gun you were forfeited
here we're a little bit more five
minutes ten minutes as you see Jennifer
uh either uh boy Chris is being there
that's very thorough yes
and that is an interesting scanner I
thought I asked him about it looks like
it's got all kinds of impressive
settings
everybody is checked carefully but what
is was interesting that the Arbiter said
yesterday during the technical meeting
that no matter what the time will start
yes we were started once at Frank
yes our chief Arbiter Chris boaters
the Chiefs
right
Marina is like
come on let's get going and you see
there's somebody else being wanted in
the back as well so there's a couple of
sections that you need to pass to be
able to participate in these vendors one
the first one and then there's Chris
bird the final box oh guys is that a
pomegranate or an apple that's an apple
how can you be so sure
look good Chris he wants a bite
bite of the Apple you know how difficult
it is to peel off a pomegranate it gets
so messy
actually I mean the plane hold is the
same one which was used for single cups
portions so we will know this plane will
hold really well you can see some snacks
for players right right there and
there's the gardening yeah even though
there were a number of players still to
be wandered their way through games
underway as we have a Wonder Liang
opening with one E4 against Wesley so
our defending champion
well I'm just so happy that this uh 2022
us Championship is underway I think for
a lot of the players here this is their
Premier event this is their opportunity
uh to shine and uh to play with the best
of the best yes and it's a mixture yes
of experienced players and Yanko
generation I mean it's very interesting
to see them fighting against those
players it's such a great opportunity
for them as well right and help me out
on this one Christian I believe a Wonder
Liang as the wild card is the wild card
in this event so for uh both events the
open as well as the women's section the
organizers have a wild card for the open
section it is indeed a Wonderland who
received the wild card deservedly so
because he's been up and coming in the
Chess World for so many years and right
now he's actually a sophomore at the
University of Chicago so he's definitely
balancing both an academic any career as
well as his chest career and he's a over
2600 level player so definitely not one
to dust off your shoulders easily
absolutely a little bit surprising for
me that after one E2 E4 Wesley's just
going through is what repertoire of what
he wanted to choose he much like the
levono ronian has been defending E7 E5
incredibly well for wow I think we see
something about six years or so in E5
and okay
um
I don't want to say it was a squandered
uh period of time you know you want to
settle in get the Zen of the tournament
Hall you know feel your self-focused but
those extra minutes pondering move one
I'd rather see uh you just be ready to
go like let's go I've seen it we've seen
it recently yes on nine LX
but maybe it's just you know a bad
habitat
to think on the first move for for a
second exactly this game and the thing
about the options that Wesley had at the
beginning of it choosing between E5
maybe something a bit more aggressive
such as uh choosing a sicilian for
example is that I wonder if I'm not
mistaken has in recent times mostly
relied on one D4 and things of that
nature so perhaps Wesley in his
preparation before the game did not
consider as much of course he considered
it you have to be ready for both E4 D4
and all the moves Knight F3 C4 and so on
but maybe he did not put as much
emphasis on the first move being one E4
and then he was just trying to figure
out his strategy am I going to use my
usual repertoire which perhaps doesn't
give me as many options and chances to
win this game against uh one of the low
rated players in the event am I going to
take any extra chances any extra risks
as well or am I going to go E5 and just
try to follow up my usual I just like
the way he said the lower rate of
players the 26.50 yeah
let's start with the ladies let's just
kind of go around a little bit as we
have this very uh big matchup in my eyes
Anna zutanski many time Champion up
against the youthful Jennifer you who's
also former Champion uh nimzo Indian
Bishop B4
Anna thinking over uh her Queen C2 the
um
the main movie the classical I want to
say we'll keep an eye on that one
another huge matchup for me these ladies
wow they uh
played against each other a lot of games
I of course I refer to Tata versus Arena
crush this is this Khan Sicilian I've
never understood it Anastasia if you've
got some insights on why the bishop is
so good on A7 I don't know but this
looks really nice
you know the idea maybe to hide it and
in case at one point it can do something
you forgot about this bishop right if it
was white and you don't remember this
song it exists but on the other hand I'm
always thinking my goodness this is a
massive hole that's not protected this
the the square on D6 with so I always
start thinking to myself well if I could
go like night here probably I have to
preface Knight C4 with A4 and put my
Bishop on F4 I'm doing great
um
again I know that this is all Theory and
a lot of moves to go still but this move
well this bishop on A7 I got bothers you
a little bit yeah what I don't
understand makes me unhappy right okay
but actually I mean it's nice to mention
that that diff played so many events
also US championships and she went she
came so close to become the the winner
yes many times but it never happened
let's say until this moment was it when
did she win one in 2011 I'm not 100 sure
I don't think so I think actually she
was nearby you know like she she's
always of course she's one of the best
players in this championship and she's
all she's a fighter so it's really
interesting to see this game with Arena
who is eight-time U.S Champion a matchup
of former world champions Sabina versus
Naji uh this system oh my gosh for white
it's the slow system it's so confounding
but if you ever want to see some great
attacking games Artur usupov plays this
very very slow system where yes he bores
you he goes Bishop B2 goes Knight D2
goes castles and somehow
he makes you
on the king side 95 and very very
dangerous keep our eye on this one
doesn't believe that dolphin I think she
plays only U.S women's championships and
it's really nice to see her back yes but
how does she overcome the rust factor I
don't know I mean my goodness my
goodness uh Megan Lee versus Rochelle
let me just bring this one up and this
one opens Sicilian the players again we
saw it the players were going through
the security checks so games are going
developing a little bit Slowly by the
way when I was playing like this was
considered a great setup for Black but
the Paul cares or the carriers attack
with G4 really scared everybody off and
so now they're playing Knight C6 and
delay to move D6 to maybe play for
Bishop B4 again we'll keep an eye on
this one
shritha oh this is like what nepo and
um
chakriar mamidarov do they don't commit
their Pawn to D4 because in their heart
of hearts they're preparing G2 G4 and
sacking the King this is going to be a
an interesting one and lastly hold on
nope I've got two more to go through
ooh an old line with A2 A4 this is the
open system well this is Bishop B5 yes
and A4 A4
I know exactly uh me either I thought
okay when is the last time I saw this
kamran shirazi a great player from the
80s open player won a lot of open
tournaments love to play like this and
then finally telia
oh A7 A6 this Magnus Carlson approach to
the Queen's Gambit declined with A6 hold
on how did she do it in which move order
A6 here
whoa that's definitely I'm gonna have to
uh get a Christian uh to check that one
for me uh Christian in the game between
Talia and Rue yangyan
um after the move Knight F3 we're all
familiar with Bishop B4 check C5 D5 gosh
no it's B6 tons of moves A7 A6 that's a
really off the Beaten Track is that the
latest and greatest it has been played a
few times uh actually
567 at times it reminds me of uh this
idea in D4 D5 C4 E6 Knight C3 and now A6
and it leads to very typical positions
after C takes D5 take Bishop to F4
you're waiting for white to commit the
placement of the dark Square Bishop
because with the Knight on F6 you also
have the option of playing the move
Bishop to G5 now if you try to waste the
tempo with let's say Knight to F3 the
problem is later on you don't have the
option as white to play the move E3
Bishop to D3 imagine this position with
the Knight on G1 and then jump with the
Knight to E2 follow it up with F3 and
the typical break in the center with E4
so it's just passing the move and saying
that you don't have any useful moves as
white without committing one of your
pieces either the bishbones you want or
the Knight on G1 to one of the squares
after f i either F4 or the square F3 for
the Knight so a very cagey approach by
black and this is what that position in
the game that we have reminds me of C4
E6 Knight to F3 of course you can go D5
and then we will have this type of
structures potentially the car's bar
structures after C takes D5 e takes D5
coming in the position as well but she
played the move A6 Knight to C3 and by
the way once again follow it up with D5
this pretty much transposes to the
positions that we just discussed and the
Knight is on F3 so you no longer have
the option of keeping the Knight on G
one and getting ready to put the Knight
on E2 this is the victory let's say
moral victory that black achieved in
this position with the move A6 and after
a c takes D5 he takes D5 Bishop to G5
Bishop to E6 E3 Knight bd7 this position
actually has been played so many times
in fact
in uh 2020 in June of 2020 we see the
game between Carlson and carwana and at
this position so definitely this was
tested at the elite of the elite levels
in chess so definitely quite an
interesting approach by uh young Rue
young Yan as well as Talia Cervantes
coming up with an interesting approach
Knight to F3 Bishop G5 E3 very typical
position now we're going to have to wait
and see how the middle game is going to
develop in this one I'm expecting
something along the lines of Queen to C2
Bishop to D3 the typical approach in the
position and then the big question will
arise are you going to go with short
Castle which I think is going to come on
the board or are you going to try to
become a bit more adventurous and play
potentially long castle and try to
launch an attack on the king side I'm
expecting white tribe with short Castle
but this one is going to be a long
strategical middle game ahead of
ourselves thank you Christian me
personally I've always been for the
heroic approach I mean somehow it really
fits very very very well let's jump to
the open and check right in on the game
between Alexander Linderman and Lavon
aronian where you just saw this last
move and I love this last move by the
way Bishop d3c2 I absolutely adore this
position for both sides what this is is
this is isolated Queen pun and when I
was a teen I literally I just stopped
and I studied isolated queen palm
positions because they come from so many
openings I'm not interested in the move
order and exactly how we got here or
there no no no I'm just interested in
the isolated Queen pawn and the typical
attacking patterns with the bishop
already developed obviously on this open
uh pardon me on this long diagonal what
I really want to do as white is make a
battery against the pawn
7. so this move Bishop C2 this we're
drawing with Bishop C2 it looks like
some passive approach no no no no it
actually threatened Queen D3 which uh
make creates the battery and I'm trying
to provoke the move G6 if I can provoke
the move G6 then I can go Bishop to H6
followed by H4 and I'll get a very very
powerful attack
lavon's answer is to play Knight to A5
intimating that what he really wants to
do is just capture this Knight and
capture this pawn and well as we say
gift me the ball
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do three immediately
exactly exactly D3 I don't have time for
that threat normally when the night goes
away it it really is kind of like would
you like to occupy the E5 Square
I move my knight away okay now I want to
play 95 and again these these wonderful
wonderful uh attacking games that I I
soared to with Michael tall and many
many others these isolated queen palm
positions I I really love them I that
it's it's what I would call the bread
and butter of the profession you really
have to know these positions let's just
jump to the game of Sam sevion and
al-shan
um okay we have a queen's Indian uh
opening with Bishop B4 check all very
standard fair so far Bishop D2 is by far
I think the main move although Knight D2
has also been tried uh the game we
started with yes was uh yes and I
actually wanted to mention that these
four nights opening right I mean this is
what you can play against the player and
the hope for quite good results yes
for example so this it's it's it
transposes very quickly to a scotch uh
with this D5 Bishop Bishop D2 yes okay
so probably the latest wrinkle will
actually have to ask Christian I just
know that this specific position has
been played hundreds of times
yeah for sure but Bishop D2 what's that
uh the latest uh Wrinkle in the scotch
yes
it has been played many many times also
many times yes many many times Bishop to
D2 Bishop to D2 Bishop takes C3 26 times
in fact and most recently between Wesley
so and Magnus Carlson we have Magnus
playing this defending it with the black
side but this is not uh Wesley's first
rodeo and perhaps he actually learned
this idea of Bishop to D2 which a wonder
is trying to assay against him in his
game against Magnus Carlsen from the
white side Wesley was white now Wesley
is black and probably knows what he
needs to do in order to equalize this
position and it does seem like the
players are well speeding through a very
forced line what we have right now on
the board well Rook B1 obviously
securing The Rook on B8 Queen cannot
move otherwise we'll just drop the Rook
nothing to be done but somehow
like Mana modern chess where you somehow
go from opening and go
you pass middle game you don't even stop
for any middle game uh look and right
into the ending is this the ending that
you were mentioning there are seven
games in this position that have been
played and all seven have finished in a
draw Yes actually we don't have draw
first so they no drawers they all have
to play this position and I think I mean
Wesley didn't look really happy
when they showed him on the screen wow
I've just uh still for for me just this
you know transition from immediately the
opening to the end game and a drawn end
game at that well that's just really
remarkable yeah they're wondering from
psychological point of view I mean like
you come to play you really want to have
a fight and then your opponent chooses
this type of opening where you the the
best thing you can do is equalize
actually exactly with black pieces yes
but still you're playing with Underdog
like how does it feel frustrating just
absolutely absolutely frustrating and I
can understand that a lot of white
players who start with one E2 E4 when
they meet a say a Petrov or they meet a
Berlin and they're like ah you know like
I wanted an open Sicilian I I had this
great novelty prepared for you so it can
be very very frustrating indeed from
Wesley's point of view draw with black
okay fine but as Christian mentioned a
wonder is not the highest rated error in
the field
so is he giving up something I don't
know we'll see who's informed let's jump
to the Junior game between
um Christopher and Hans Neiman this
looks like a London which no Knight C3
aggressive what is it what's this Knight
C3 life Versace
I had somehow I Associated it with no I
think what's one night C3 called that's
a Romanian opening what that's what I
think it's the Romanian opening
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
no like Knight C3 and then you play a
three four something like that right so
something like Knight C3 yeah I know
your first movement 93 and
so usually I remember there was some
line that went like this and I as a kid
I really got into it but uh never mind
uh it looks like a pretty decent London
from White's perspective because the
night is offside on A6 what's the
theoretical
um but okay it is it is off-site but at
some point uh I will play the move C6
okay we'll have to retreat with the
Knight back to C3 and most likely I will
follow it up maybe immediately or after
developing my pieces uh with Bishop to
D7 with the move C5
and then I will be able to challenge
your Center just like that if you do
take on C5 as white then my knight
finally gets back in the game and I take
C5 so I wouldn't be too worried about
that now I also have the Avenue after I
cleared out this uh Square C6 to reroute
my Knight Knight to B4 and then get it
back to C6 that's his let's say natural
position and uh this sort of situations
so sure the Knight on A6 but the general
type of position right now is not a very
Dynamic one right it's quite static it's
very uh maneuvering uh dependence so I
do have time it feels like to just
improve the position of that Knight on
Asics fair enough uh close position you
you get a lot of Tempe to maneuver
around I'm just thinking that from
White's point of view sometimes this
bishop on F4 gets harassed by Knight on
H5 and I kind of just feel like white
for the moment has a decent uh London
system we'll see Jeffrey versus Darwish
I noticed that in this line
of the Queen's Indian by the way was
very recently played in fact the first
round of the European Team Championships
that are currently taking place
world champion Magnus Carlson is on the
black side playing a lower rated player
and the lower rate of play with white
had no problems making a very easy draw
against the world champion world
champion was frustrated with the black
pieces b2b3 was not the approach of the
opponent of
um Magnus Magnus actually ended up
facing something with a very quick and
Bishop F4 and Rook C1 B2 B3
um again very standard approach uh White
looking to play Bishop B2 Knight will
come out to C3 Rooks to the center play
for E2 E4
now this is again this is an opening
where I think
of games in the database have been
played Sam Shanklin versus Ray Robson
and this is a real Clash of the
Olympians uh these guys are top top
players and give us a breakdown of the
of the position between Sam and Ray I
think Cutting Edge Christian of uh the
latest and greatest well it does here
like there was one game actually played
in this position they are following the
game between one Cuba pietor and sikora
Joseph from 2013 my assumption is that
this is a correspondence game
um very interesting position it does
feel like black is taking some risks by
choosing to Castle long side and not the
short side the typical way but it does
seem like the way white arranged their
pieces he's ready to go F4 he's ready to
go King two H1 and then just try to take
advantage of the fact that I have a
clear way of changing the structure in
the position and potentially infusing
some Dynamic play in the game with the
move F4 so I'm definitely looking at
that typical idea for White Knight to C4
King to H1 followed by A4 the question
is how are you going to tackle that are
you actually going to try to stop me
with a move such as G5 I can definitely
see that happening in the future but
right now with the Rook on A1 you have
to be careful because I have a clear
threat and that is to take on B6 I don't
think you want to take with the a pawn
for example if you play a move such as
G5 take on B6 you have to take with the
a pawn if you take with the c or the
Knight then I'm just simply going to
pick up the pawn on a7a you do take with
the a pawn Rook to A8 Knight to B8 it
just doesn't look right first of all
that's one of the problems but also I
can just simply continue with Queen to
G4 Bishop to E3 Queen to A1 Queen 287 at
some point I will create some a very
very critical uh difficulties on the
queen side for your king it's not
looking good so you have to do something
about that first after Knight to C4 you
have this problem to address how are you
going to address it either with King to
B8 which defends the entry Square as
well as the pawn on A7 so for example
King to B8 if you do take on B6 now I
have options I don't have to take with
the a pawn and probably I will not
because then once again I will get
killed on the a file we don't want to
see that on the board but what I can do
is take with a c Pawn or take with the
Knight on B6 definitely looking much
healthier for black or you can just
simply go with the move A6 very
intriguing position once again we have
one of those positions that is going to
develop slowly why it is going to try
first of all black will probably defend
against this immediate threat white is
going to try to go King to H1 F4 and
create some more weaknesses on the king
side and in the center
but coach uh it hasn't Sam violated our
Cardinal rules of never moving the same
piece twice in the opening
took a journey to G5 and then all the
way back to C4 what what's up with all
those loss of Tempe it's a slow type
maneuvering position also if you look at
what black did he played the move Bishop
to C5 then Bishop to B6 the Knight to F6
Knight to D7 so you did spend some time
as well losing a lot of tempies
um it's just one of those typical
maneuvering positions and Knight to G5
had a clear idea behind it you want to
address that Bishop on E6 right so Force
black to do something and in this case
black decided to just give up the two
Bishop advantage in the position with
Bishop takes B3 still a very complex and
a very tense middle game ahead of us and
A6 was his choice to defend on the a
file so real master class going on here
and I have a question yes please I'd try
to understand I mean is it a good idea
now to take this bishop or let's say the
bishop can run away absolutely I do want
to take it yes for all of the reasons
that Christian was saying most
importantly I want to say It's
associated with this move F2 F4
um if I let that Bishop live the bishop
will go back and maybe if I wait too
long also G7 G5 will stop F4 no it's not
Mike I play F4 and thank you I win the
game please sign my score sheet it's
just that this is actually a very nice
uh break for white to get in you may
follow it up with Queen check and
captures I don't think it took on B6
should I take with the pawn on B6 he did
not take on business he didn't take it
oh he did so this night he played King
H1 perhaps
yes
H1 so the argument is is this Knight is
better than this bishop I like this
decision you like that Yes actually the
engines uh do agree with you I do say
that Knight takes B6 is maybe the better
option but I do like leaving more pieces
on the board why am I saying that
because that Knight on C4 not only that
it Taps the bishop on B6 on the shoulder
but also the pawn on E5
so I'm going to follow it up with F4
that's my clear idea in the position and
I'm going to have an extra attacker on
the pawn on E5 I'm going to put more and
more pressure through the presence of
the Knight on C4 so I definitely prefer
living that night there actually it's
really difficult to get rid of this
Knight on
c45 yes it's kind of awkward to be sure
okay but I'll play The Devil's Advocate
for just a moment and I'll say I respect
I respect your idea of f4 so much I'm
going to shut it down I want to play G5
even at the cost of potentially you know
getting having an uh a very weak Square
well now that you mentioned it let's go
Bishop E3 yeah
Bishop on B6 take with the bishop yes 93
and then 93. so let's say I take with
the point I'm going to make a little
cocoon you know like a cave for my king
and then Knight E3 I agree you've got a
knight on a good square but even I and
you don't have to rush uh apologies if I
uh make moves for you uh you put your
knight on F5 I okay I mean it's not that
again it's not the end of the world
you've got I remember Victor course I
saying to me you know
you've got a beautiful piece what about
the rest
you know like the Rook on F1 is kind of
saying okay Rook on A1 is okay but I
think you're gonna have to do more to
win the game with white I don't know
exactly what that is B4 B5 when
brilliantly G2 G3 okay well that exposes
your king a little bit but uh big fight
going on here I'll we'll definitely keep
our eye on this one and finally I for me
the Marquee matchup uh between Fabi and
Lanier these two heavyweights boy do
they know one another and in fact
Christian you can talk to this uh linear
help Fabi and His World Championship
campaign he did indeed yes he helped
Fabi and then Lanier started uh playing
the Petrov defense
the year following those training camps
so they definitely fed off each other's
knowledge in uh those training camps
they know each other very well and we've
seen in the recently concluded sync Phil
cup actually it was Fabiano who decided
to start also with a move E4 and Lanier
decided to go with the Petrov defense
but he got in big trouble in uh that
game he was completely losing twice in
that game and it was only the fact that
Fabiano was unable to confirm his Edge
and did not find the best moves at the
critical moment and allowed Lanier to
escape but definitely it felt like there
was some pressure uh boiling in that
Petra of Defense Lanier decides to
sidestep that with the Berlin in this
one and the Berlin of course we know
most E4 players that quit playing E4
such as myself they did it because of
the Berlin the Berlin is such a
difficult knot to crack and this is
exactly what we're seeing right now but
Fabiano comes with a very interesting
idea this Castle Knight AC4 D4 Knight D6
and D takes E5 not Bishop takes C6
that's the main line which leads uh to
the end game that we all know so well
and we also know that it's extremely
difficult to find the advantage there so
he decides on a very interesting new
novel Approach at least at the elite
level I haven't seen this being played
in a very long time in general it's
considered to be quite equal but he
plays this not Knight takes D4 and then
D5 that's an option as well and by the
way this is very typical we've seen this
so many times D5 e takes D6 Queen takes
D6 Queen to E4 Queen to E6 Queen to D4
Queen to D6 we all know this line so
well right there has been countless of
draws at the elite level in this
particular instance but after D5
what 1966 was played not he takes D6
which allows Knight takes D4 and uh then
Queen takes D4 Queen to D6
but Knight takes D6 and queen D3 a very
interesting wrinkle and at the position
S8 by Fabiano caruana and that actually
allowed him to gain quite a significant
Edge on his clock let's take a look at
the clocks guys
one hour and 28 minutes for Fabiano
right now one hour and 12 minutes for
Lanier and Fabiano is still blitzing out
his moves yes he's playing uh Allah
Temple absolutely A5 big threat of
course you want to go be space six win
an exchange you have to sidestep that
diagonal with the move Queen to E3 he
played it so fast he's definitely ready
for it and this is going to be a very
double-edged game because as black if
you try to go Bishop E7 and then go long
castle and things of that nature well
that's going to allow me to go F4 F5 if
I manage to get that pawn to F5 and then
be ready to push it all the way to F6
well you're going to start shaking in
your boots because I mean with the queen
coming to G3 putting a lot of pressure
on the G file it's not such an easy game
and you know Fabiano Heap this is
probably the beginning of his
preparation right let's say maybe
following year you know we know him also
has a really greater Edition but he's
out of his authority knowledge right now
or at least he's trying to remember what
he studied maybe six months ago it's not
as easy he wasn't prepared for this
particular move A4 in the opening
definitely I have to say I have to give
it to Fabiano in the opening phase I
think he won the opening battle
uh now having said that uh Christian I
see this move Queen E3 and I kind of see
the Dual Purpose the first as you say
you want to sidestep the threat threat
is losing the exchange you don't want to
get scared so the move Queen E3 the
queen kind of hangs out there in the
center of the board maybe maybe on a
very good day you start to grab some
dark squares like the D4 and the C5
Square you also mentioned that F2 F4 F5
is maybe on the agenda now having said
all of that
I see the queen on E3 and I'm thinking
to myself my Bishop on C8 needs a life
now if I could put the bishop on the
long diagonal Bishop on B7 and queen G4
why aren't you encouraging me with the
move Queen E3 to play the move D5 D4
very committal move yes early I mean to
say but I look at it and I think to
myself okay all I need is that want to
move and if you played Queen G3 which
may be the queen then I'll think okay
well that's Queen G4 let's let's trade
them off why isn't D5 D4 good it's a
great move that's why you are four time
usually yeah
we know you can see some really good
moves D4 is a good move and I have to
say probably a practical decision as
well it's very nicely coupled with the
idea of the last few moves of blacks we
know that in general you don't want to
put the queen in front of the bishop
with this move Queen to D7 but what
you're trying to do is challenge White's
plan and what is White's plan well
White's plan is to go Queen to G3 and
put a lot of pressure on the pawn G7 so
for example if you try to develop your
pieces nicely and harmoniously with the
move Bishop to E7 after Queen G3 you're
already in some sort of danger because
if you follow it up with Castle well
Bishop to H6 comes you lose the exchange
after G6 and you're actually just in a
lost position so you cannot do that
after Queen to G3 you're already forced
almost to play moves such as King 2 f8
you don't want to play G6 that's going
to allow me to go pitch page six this is
not looking good for the black side so I
really like this move Queen to D7
what queen to D7 is trying to get ready
for for example if you go something like
Knight C3 I'm just making a normal move
Bishop to E7 and now Queen to G3 I have
the extra option of challenging your
queen with the move Queen to G4 in the
position given that I have the two
Bishops and my position despite the fact
that I have the Double C points is quite
healthy I'm going to be able to go Rook
to B8 put some pressure on the B file
the end game definitely favors black I'm
going to have extreme control over the
light squares Bishop to F5 comes back
attacking the pawn on C to putting a lot
of pressure on wise position white does
not want to exchange the queens and this
is why I like Queen to D7 so much it
definitely seemed like a linear new
about this move Queen to D7 Knight to D2
A5 Queen to E3 this is what we have D4
the move that you mentioned the answer I
like it but I also like it because after
Queen to G3 I'm going to have ideas of
Queen to G4 I'm always hunting your
queen somehow if you play the move Queen
to F3 I'm going to continue hunting your
queen with the move Queen to D5 I can do
that or I can just simply play this move
Rook to A6 I like this move guys I
really like this move why do I like it
because I know I'm going to follow it up
with the move C5 and try to put the
bishop on the long diagonal as you
specified at the beginning of your
speech right this is why you play the
move d4 to open up the long diagonal get
Bishop to B7 not only that but after
remove C5 I'm also opening up the route
for my Rook to come to G6 and
potentially creating Havoc around your
King on the G file so definitely a very
intriguing position what would worry me
in the position as black is that Fabiano
once again knows exactly where he is in
the position and knows exactly how to
test you in the next few moves even if
you play the move d4 or C5 you can start
with the move C5 as well this seems to
be the computers wreck recommendation
and in fact this computer this engine
gives black a slight Advantage I don't
think that's the case from a practical
perspective I don't think that's the
case definitely an intriguing and let's
say risk taking initiative by Fabiano
caruana in game one against linear
Dominguez thank you for that question
even though this is a very early moment
of the first round Messi is the game
between Christopher and Hans and when we
left it we left it exactly in these in
this moment I remember what you said
yeah and it's it's a really nice uh
Bishop on F4 like you've got this great
London system is white and Hans
understood that he said no no I'm not
going to live with that Bishop on F4
Knight H5 and this is a nice little move
uh Bishop E5 it induces black to
um weaken his King side ever so much uh
if the bishop had simply just dropped
back then after for example not
necessarily immediately uh there's a
capture I open up the H uh H file and
you think to yourself gosh if I had this
position as white you know what I'd
really love to see is a really stupid
move like F7 F6 I'd like now black to
play the move F7 F6 how am I going to
get him to do that well that's why
Christopher played the move Bishop Q5
provoking F6 and as Christian said this
Knight on B5 is actually pretty darn
bothersome if you don't get rid of it
soon c2c4 attacking in the center is
going to come so we did see C7 C6 and C6
C5 also because it's kind of so closed
you think that this Knight might even
make some trip over to the king side no
instead of Hans Neiman C5 and I think
are we still in the databases uh
Christian for this position c65 no no no
no no no no this is naturally novelty at
least according to my database C5 was uh
the novelty and I was mentioning this
this is what probably black wants to do
C6 get kick the Knight away from B5 and
then follow it up with C5 empty that
square C6 for the Knight because you
want to get the Knight back to C6 via B4
or B8 even B8 in some instances C5 seems
to be the first new move in the position
still very balanced zero zero zero
everywhere in the position you can start
off with Castle you can go with the move
A3 you have a lot of plans available for
white in the position I have to say as I
look at this game it does feel like
black equalized out of the opening I
don't see any reminiscent of any sort of
attack for white in this situation
definitely if you're like Hans equalized
in this game well let me play the
devil's advocate here once and more uh
no attack or white but I'm gonna try to
force you to open up the H file with a
move Knight D2 when uh my Rook when I
haven't castled so if we go takes takes
takes and I don't know
um
the night before Bishop D7
give me a move that you like sure let's
go Bishop B7 Bishop D7 and well let's go
Bishop to D3
F5 let's go well I think it's safe to
say that well we should probably show G6
right I should probably show what
happens after G6 okay because you you
are waiting for this yeah you're waiting
for me
puzzle Rush
seven right yes I'm thinking about a
queen H5 yes yes by the way uh I must
say that I love the puzzle brush contest
on the chess.com uh but I know Ray
Robson in the field is monstrous in this
oh he's he's a world champion I I think
he's a world champion in puzzle rush or
something like that my gosh I mean he
just solves these in in record time and
uh well hats off to Ray uh but yes
exactly so Bishop D3
um uh F5 and then Queen H5 H6 now yes
you have to play H6 and I don't know I'm
just like
again my heroic style I can't stop
myself uh probably I have nothing but
but it looks scary I have to remove like
night before maybe neutralizing but uh
well I like these H file attacks by none
of this Christopher just said he he
nothing doing I'm just gonna Castle
after C5 and you're welcome to take my
Bishop on G3 without consequence and
know which file no H5 okay guys I've got
to put you guys on the spot and uh this
is what it's all about I mean we talked
about the prize fund for the players but
for the commentators and extra price
fund for the brilliant decision of who's
going to be the 2022 US Champions
Anastasia uh
ladies first as we say uh take a look at
the field and the ladies here I'll bring
it up on my board once more and you've
got you've got some tough choices here
of course it's really tough let me
choose uh this time
yes because she tried so many times she
never managed to do so and I think it's
gonna be interesting she she will be
ever so grateful very very very grateful
by the way coming into the competition
which seating number is she she is
number seven I see all right
so you're right you're definitely and uh
Christian please please I want to give
you guys every opportunity I usually
don't do this but for this one I'm going
to pick my players uh my students
actually well students is a big word I
guess I'm going to go with gulrook begin
Tokyo Nova
um in the ladies section who played
magnificently in the Olympiad on board
one she did yes she definitely held her
board no losses four wins if I'm not
mistaken and actually that allowed the
ladies to get all the way to Fourth
position in the Olympian a great result
for the ladies that started as seventh
see in that competition uh beg him I
will take her in the lady section in the
open section I will go with my guy
Fabiano caruana of course
my co-host look I mean if you're gonna
have a podcast
you know you're like you're just not
possible that's why I didn't even try it
right I used to avoid it look I used to
avoid it I used to say some other names
or something along those lines like
Jeffrey perhaps right but on this one I
would have to go with Fabi I I think he
knows that he needs this one not only
for himself but also for the growth of
the podcast
be all important all important and of
course we're going to get varusian and
also to throw in his uh comments and in
the open uh in the oven I thought to go
with Jeffrey song
with Jeffrey I think if he's really he
really deserves between the championship
he worked so hard lately and he showed
with his results also that he is one of
the top players in U.S so I think it's
going to be interesting wow
interestingly I think Jeffrey is also
the seventh seed ah yes so in both cases
I'm looking for Dark Horses
tournaments for sure and now that Fabian
has taken what could I do last time I
took Fabiano he won the event okay
enough is enough Christian learned his
lesson and he took him back yes I am
going to go uh with Jennifer you and I
think Youth and she's coming
full of women Vigor but in the open I'm
gonna go with Lavon remember Levon is uh
his debut 40 years young
how many opportunities is he going to
have in the future of winning I think
he's
absolutely absolutely motivated in this
tournament and he's about to be a father
by the way exactly that's a great
motivation exactly so Lavon
oh no I've got a I've got I'm carrying
VAR I'm carrying vark on my shoulders he
also he also took levonne and Jennifer
wow and Jennifer it's it's interesting
that nobody actually choose the arena
crash
but it doesn't mean that we still
consider them as one of the main
competitors of course in this event just
we decided to have let's say some fun
probably Let's see we like The Underdogs
yes right yeah we like this panel it
seems like and I see in back of you that
Lanier didn't go for the D4 immediately
he played for C5 uh I I like this move
as well and that move Rook A6 which
stopped by the way Fabi in his tracks
ooh author C5 right now Fabiano is
thinking so I don't think he's out of
his book just yet but it definitely
start to be looking like a very sharp
potential middle game coming in this one
because the way I see white has to do
something if you allow me to go Bishop
B7 or k6 Bishop B7 castle and solve all
my problems not get under uh a mating
attack on the king side then I'm going
to be in trouble that's why because your
Bishops are going to explode once you
open up that long diagonal long A8 to H1
diagonal and activate the bishop on B7
I'm going to have huge problems I don't
want to see that on the board so what I
have to do is try to take you out on the
king side how do I do that just push the
pause with the move F4 so this is what I
think we're going to see in this
position do you have time to play the
move Rook to A6 and try to go to G6
probably not I'm going to continue with
the move F5 taking away the squares from
your but most importantly right now
after Bishop to E7 one once again not
only that I took away the squares from
your Rook but I also intercepted this
diagonal and queen to G4 doesn't come in
the position anymore so I can just
simply go Queen to G3 Queen to G4 is no
longer possible and if you Castle well
after F6 you can resign sign the score
sheets and go home because this game is
over so you cannot do that now what are
you going to do after uh F5 probably
you're already in a bad position so you
have to stop me from playing the move F5
with the move G6 not an easy move to
make but definitely something that
linear will be considering in the
position you're weakening a lot of dark
squares around your king but maybe take
advantage of the fact that you haven't
committed the bishop to E7 and try to
get it to G7 in one move with the move
Bishop to G7 just fiancato the bishop
that's one way another way is that I was
thinking about was to potentially get
the queen to F5 but it doesn't seem like
this is a correct move because after the
move B3 now the consequences of the move
Bishop a queen to F5 is that your queen
is very very far from the pawn C5 this
is the critical weakness right now in
your position so the way I'm going to
try to tackle that is via the move B3 B3
Bishop to A3 Rook to C1 if you dare
touch that pawn on C2 which I don't
think you will you're losing too many
tempies and you're going to be in deep
trouble so definitely a fiery approach
by Fabiano caruana and we could
potentially see a melee in this one if
he does go for this move F4 very very
intriguing position in this one guys
okay could you put that position with F4
Rook A6 again on your board yes is
already a bad move after that yeah and
and after F5 I I understand it's a very
consequential decision by black but the
move G7 G6 it's exactly in this moment
it basically means I'm not castling
Queen side obviously yeah not for
castling King site but I'm provoking you
to sacrifice upon I will with E6 I will
and I take it probably take it right yes
I push and you probably have to stop me
right
with Queen 127 the problem is yeah I
have the Knight coming in and then night
is coming to either E5 or are you trying
not to stop me with
Bishop to D6 allow me to go F7 I'm I'm
you know where what I like is a a a a
home for my my king queen C6 sure okay
F7 King D7 Knight F3 Bishop D6 or G7
Knight to E5 and then I can even go
yes Pawn is going to promote somehow I
wanted to get the move D5 D4 in you
don't have time you don't have time and
even if you do get the move d4 and then
Bishop to B7 that's why I just simply
defend with the move Rook to F2
I don't think you're going to be able to
continue after that
okay wow it looks scary yeah yeah
uh quickly turning to the game of Anna
satonski and Jennifer you uh it reminds
me of the Smithson variation the nimsa
with this early Bishop to D2 Ana is one
of those players where I think she feels
the most comfortable when the opening is
over just give her a playable position
where she said yeah where she's not in
the bowels of theory and has to know 20
moves of Chess but plays just very
natural game Rook to C1 was her last
move
anticipating that Knight takes C3 will
be answered by Rook take C3 then she
wants to use the C file to press against
the C Pawn from Jennifer's point of view
a move like Knight D7 I seem to remember
having studied a lot of me sloths games
where he ended up preserving the two
Bishops with this move Bishop C3 to E1
in his career and where would you like
to take us uh we've got seven wonderful
ladies games Anastasia which game
um which game we would like to see maybe
actually touch over Sabrina well now
that you've chosen Tata have you've got
skin in the game and this to remind
everybody this was the Khan
with Bishop to A7 Knight C3 and this
looks all standard when I see this move
D7 D6 by the way by Arena I thought hey
that's a good relief yeah white is not
occupying the square
D6 and then she can play either E5 and
Bishop E6 or B5 anyway Bishop E3 on the
board B5
whoa Tata make a very challenging
decision here Christian I mean uh Arena
said look I'm gonna I'm gonna expand on
the queen side and Tata if we say walked
into it let's go challenge let's see 97
F4 B4 Knight B1
I'm anticipating that we'll see castles
and A5 in the very near future are we
still in theory Christian some sort of
uh obscure Theory I think there's only
like oh obscure is it four games being
played in this one and not between very
strong players I think one of them in
1992 between
Ernst and sunya Nito Jaime you probably
know this place yes yes
NATO played in my world junior Champion
really really yeah okay from Brazil uh
after Henry making he was one of this
very very strongest players to emerge
out well he was 2500 in 1992 so that's
pretty strong when that got you in the
top 100 or so in the world is pretty
good I'm sure Kristen didn't expect you
knew everyone but break down the
position for us a little bit uh
Christian right I'm looking at tata's
position and I'm saying why isn't why
are these night nights tailor-made for a
pond storm it's not looking good I have
to say B4 you usually want to answer
that with potentially Knight to A4 at
least stop the Pawns in their tracks
right A5 A4 is not going to come you
don't want to see Knight to B1 I
understand that you have your own attack
Brewing on the king side as well with
the move G4 g5h4h5 but it's so far away
right and both of your Knights and this
is a key point that you mentioned yes
sir both of your Knights are not helping
the attack Knight on B3 is not helping
the attack Knight on B1 is not helping
the attack in fact they're not helping
your attack they're helping my attack
right because I go before I gain a Tempo
I go A5 I go A4 I gain another Tempo
that's two moves and this is look look
what she's doing she just played the
move A5 she's not even going to Castle
I'm going to leave the king in the
center of the board and I'm just going
to say you're way too far from my king
with after the move G4 you don't have
enough time to do all of those things to
open up the position in the center and
on the king side in the meantime I go A5
I hit your knight away you probably want
to do something because I think you want
to return this Knight to D4
unfortunately if you go G4 A4 Knight to
D4 is not possible because you don't
have enough Defenders so you have to
take the passive approach with the move
Knight to D2 what is this Knight doing
on B1 exactly probably just keeping a
defensive stature for the moment but
it's not looking good all I have to do
in the position is focus on the C file
focus on the king left on C1 you have so
many moves that you have to make in
order to be able to hide the king to be
one or A1 so you're very far away from
that and we're not even talking about
developing an attack on the king side
I'm definitely preferring Black's
position and this one even from a
practical perspective not only that
after A5 the computer is saying 0 0
maybe a little bit better for a black
but from a practical perspective it just
feels like the attack Flows In Black's
favor
it's just uh you know when I'm playing
uh in competitive tournament at chess
for me I just always love it when I have
clear natural moves and a move like A5
and playing A4 these are really natural
whereas tatav
she has to
think is E5
the first move F5 G4 Her Moves aren't as
easy and as simple to play and just to
stop using this track I apologize for
that yesterday I do think that we're
going to see a result anytime soon
because Alex Lenderman right now has the
opportunity to go a knight to F3 and
repeat the position for the third time I
see so Knight to F3 Knight to A5 Knight
to uh E5 Knight to C6 these dance of
knights has been happening for the last
30 minutes in the position and the last
few moves on the board and right now
with the move Knight to F3 Lenderman can
just stop the clock and say Arbiter with
this move I repeat the position three
times I want to make a draw wow all
right interesting which means that
basically two best players can be
stopped like this you know they can they
can lose half a point let's say lose
half a point uh yeah you go and beat
blender with uh White not so easy but it
was interesting because when we left it
I thought the move Knight A5 was an
invitation to step up with Knight E5 and
then Knight C6 and as Christian has been
saying they've been dancing back and
forth with those two knights I suppose
if I could just uh play it for just a
moment a move like Queen D3 uh you've
got a queen takes D5 uh would walk into
Knight takes C6 but
this particular ending doesn't really
impress that much does it I mean like I
don't particularly see why black has
anything to worry about there so draw a
little disappointing as you say it may
be a little frustrating a little bit
frustrating for the player who wants to
you know in the beginning
and uh I think we're getting ready for
break before we go on break we've got to
find out what our good friends at Q
Boutique are offering yeah today it's a
time for Q Boutique and we have the book
from Jenny Karen singfield yes okay so
let me just tell you the story about
this book for just a second so Jeannie
uh the wife of Rex now Genie has her
interest in music and uh the Scouts of
America she's at all of these dinners
where everybody's going Bishop F6 Knight
F6 Queen F6 she's looking at us as we're
talking Greek she says well what you
know like I want to be a part of the
conversation how can I talk chess what
are these guys talking about so she
decided to write a book yes this book is
actually called learn to read and write
chess and it's a perfect especially for
absolute beginners exactly yes uh how do
if your mom or dad and your kid is
talking with his best friend or her best
friend about Chess uh and then yes Genie
exploited uh all of the people who come
to the St Louis chess club my wife who's
Dutch she said could you translate it
yes
did she get you a Christian to do the
Romanian Edition I did I did you did the
real baby she's exploited everybody so I
think it's done for Ukraine Ukraine yes
in any case anybody who would like to
have this book you can buy it in our
cubic shop it's definitely recommended
for the beginners absolutely and we'll
see you on the other side of the break
right
[Music]
you may have heard about St Louis's
world-class Museums Art History Science
even magic
but you may not know we have an entire
Museum dedicated to play with a 10 story
slide and a ferris wheel on top
don't let all this family fun Slide by
you
[Music]
yes it is
St Lou is always exploring anybody
[Music]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
Corey family Welcome to our show
[Music]
you guys
[Music]
foreign
celebrating its 200th anniversary
offering world-class education in the
heart of St Louis SLU attracts students
and professors from around the globe
in 2015 slew partnered with the St Louis
chess club to start a top-tiered
Collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the team's Inception slew
obtained second best university of the
Pan-American Intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose greater good
St Louis University
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone here we are back
to Saint Louis chess club me and Joseph
ceremon Anastasia is wonderful to be
with you hello everyone as we resume our
coverage of round one and let's just
jump into one of these games I just I
was speaking earlier about an isolated
Queen Pond position I just love these
games uh the one between Sam Shanklin
and Ray Robson were kings are castled on
opposite sides of the board when you see
this setup
it's almost like you the ringing of the
Bell that means I get to attack you on
the queen side in this case Ray robson's
King is over there and black says yeah
well okay I get to attack you and we see
uh this Pawn storm G5 and H5 coming down
on the king side and Sam has just
initiated his own attack on the queen
side with the move B3 B4 and
and by the way we do we have the first
result already as we see uh uh it was
difficult though with a repetition right
repetition for both yes sides uh I'm
gonna say Christian that this was all
theory that uh occurred between Lavon
of the players
as we see the AAA
yeah Christian pickup if you will it's
all Theory absolutely so these are the
players that actually played this game
before it is Tarzan versus rashevsky yes
sir you should probably know this game
from 1976. oops wow
I think it was Knight to F3 as well in
that game in fact actually it wasn't
right F3 it was Knight takes C6 that was
played in that game the only Knight C6
ever played in this position Knight A6
Bishop A6 and actually the game
continued it ended up in a draw between
these two legends one of them uh was
inducted into the U.S Chess Hall of Fame
yesterday actually absolutely uh Jim
Tarzan it was a marvelous ceremony
yesterday at the opening ceremony as we
have these inductees uh the World Chess
Hall of Fame which is the fide arm of a
world
um players had three and that was Judith
Paul and
it was actually so nice to see a Torah
here right at the ceremony yes it's a
bit Judy couldn't do it this time but
she promised to come back exactly and
James Tarzan from the American side John
Watson and Daniel Fisk from the 19
pardon me 1857 American Congress so the
first idea of having these Swiss
congresses led to Paul Murphy winning
the competition and Paul morphy went on
to become literally the world's first
celebrity and I'm not saying chess
celebrity but celebrity his name was his
name was known throughout the world for
his seances he did these blindfold
simultaneous and he was exalted but I'm
going to jump over to you Christian as
we have special guests in studio
absolutely I am here with the executive
director of the Saint Louis chess club
Tony Tony uh please uh tell us a little
bit about this situation that is
developing in the Chess World with one
of the players here at the USS Champion
uh ship Hans Limerick
okay
uh yeah so uh during the singfield cup
uh Magnus Carlson is everybody knows
withdrew from the event
um subsequently has accused tons of
cheating uh in chess uh there was a
report that came out from chess.com just
yesterday in fact that details some of
that cheating uh specifically in online
chess play and draw some questions about
some of his over-the-board play as well
and what is the official position right
now of the Saint Louis chess club
related to this drama
well
um
you know Jonathan Ralston sent out a a
tweet earlier that I thought kind of
sums it up nicely has Hans cheated over
the board uh we don't know cert for
certain has he cheated online yes
admittedly he has do we still have to
assume that he's innocent until he's
proven guilty and the answer to that is
yes so uh if and until U.S chess or fide
or some other authoritative governing
body decides to investigate and take
action
um it behooves organizers to lead
players and and let them play their
events and I think it's worth mentioning
that the contracts and the invitations
for this USS championships have been
sent long time ago can you talk about
the selection process as well a little
bit sure so the U.S Championship field
is really determined by July that's when
the rating lists come out that the event
is based on so um from from that
perspective you're right Hans was
already signed and ready to go before
the singfield cup started I can also say
that the chess club doesn't um we don't
have the authority to select players for
the national championships we submit a
bid to the U.S trust Federation and U.S
chess is responsible for determining how
players can make it into the event
typically players make it in by rating
and through qualifying events we do have
one wild card in the U.S Championship
this year and that was our pick that's a
Wonder Liang but Hans qualified to play
the U.S championship by winning the 2021
U.S junior Championship and I actually
called that tournament as well and I
remember it was an incredible
performance by Hanzo definitely deserved
to be here in the U.S Chess Championship
and also we've seen that the measures
the anti-cheating measures have been
strengthened at the St Louis chess club
talk about that a bit sure obviously we
want to ensure that our events are held
with the highest Integrity possible we
want to ensure fair play across all the
tournaments I want the players to feel
comfortable knowing that when they come
to play in St Louis that we take it very
seriously so for example this year we've
implemented additional security measures
we we've always had the metal detecting
wands we've added to that the radio
frequency scanners that check for any
signaling that's happening in the room
we've implemented additional scanners
that check for any silicon devices so
that would be any Electronics on a
person regardless of whether they're
powered on or off regardless of whether
they're transmitting a signal or not
these devices would detect that
electronic So Physical scanning we also
have the game analysis by Ken Reagan
which he continues to provide for us and
in addition to that we've implemented a
30 minute delay on this broadcast
all of those things combined uh adding
to that the fact that no Spectators are
allowed in the playing Hall the only
folks in there right now are the players
the Arbiters the events staff and select
media any media that's present in the
playing Hall is always accompanied by
chess club staff they too must leave
their electronic devices out of the
playing hole so I really believe that
we've implemented some best of breed
practices here in this tournament Tony I
think that pretty much clears the air
thank you very much for joining the show
and well you have a lot of work to do so
good luck in that thank you a quick
question for you Tony because I get this
a lot a lot of people ask me
how did the organizers of the Cinco cup
feel when Magnus withdrew did you
how did I feel how did you feel yes well
Yasser he asked all the hard questions
um do I think it was appropriate for
Magnus to withdraw from the singfield
cup no
um do I think the fact that he withdrew
from the sinkfield cup has drawn
attention to a cheating problem that
exists in the Chess World yes
did that answer your question yes sir
pretty much just wanted and the feedback
also is the St Louis chess club Rex
everybody's committed uh to further
tournaments including the sink fill Cup
this wasn't like a death blow to to the
sinful cup
thank you Dory
thank you Tony indeed and by the way uh
we've already had one draw in the open
but it sure looks to me as I'm studying
the game between uh a Wonder Liang and
Wesley so that this four versus four
Rook ending is definitely heading for a
draw not much to say about the game
except for this nice little move here
right here after the move Rook takes A7
I really liked this Precision I want to
say by Wesley I like including this Rook
C3 check you could have taken the pawn
of course but why not take the pawn was
a gain of a Tempo with a check and after
H5 we're we're up to date with the
players and anticipating a draw this one
I see that we've got Sam Shanklin and
Ray Robson on the board over here let me
just switch to that very interesting
yeah
how are okay like you look at this
position and you know what you've got to
do Anastasia you've got to bring the
heat uh to whites King and to blacks
right you mentioned that this Knight on
C4 but it it's not like you can just go
c2c4 would how would you think you're
supposed to open up the position it's
not so easy is it yeah so for example I
mean you don't read the point probably
take on B6 and then play C4 right this
three Pawn will be kind of weak
backwards yeah yes so
um and I'm not sure but
maybe it's something like this is
possible also like I always think about
this option that if black go too far
away with their with his pawns maybe you
can at this moment take on B6 the same
idea I remember from Christian like take
on B6 and then play 93. later on so like
always you have it in the air they said
yeah okay just to repeat what you've
said so something like I can trade and
then here stop this bonds for for
example and jump in protect your king
and then maybe think about some moves
like C4 B5 later on exactly yeah I don't
know with these double pawns a Christian
it's not easy for white to open up uh
things on the queen side I'm thinking
specifically in the game between Sam
Shanklin and Ray well luckily we
actually have one of the top players
with us here is with us so maybe he can
discuss at that position as well Lavon
you finished uh your first game in the
U.S chess champion uh ship uh in a drop
quite a quick draw tell us a bit about
that
um yeah we got this variation uh that uh
I've played with white and black and I
think I knew it a bit more than my
opponent and I knew that this Knight A5
idea is important
otherwise blood can be slightly worse
after A3 Bishop B7 Bishop to C2 Knight
to A5 yeah uh describe to us the details
of this movement so the point is if if
you just like make a pass instead of 95
proxy yeah Queen D3 comes and it's quite
unpleasant because you have to commit
already with G6 Bishop H6
and RKA through 81
it's uh it's playable for black but
I think it's easier for white to play
because
he has attacking ideas here and why does
Knight A5 change things in the position
why can white just play Queen yeah he
can but then you can take on F3 and take
on D4 so you would pick up the pawn
and it seems it works because Queen lc4
is protected yeah so Bishop to E3 Queen
to C4 or even Queen to G4 in this case I
think it's Bishop F4 the move here of
course there's a compensation provided
but Quincy 4 I think
it's not too scary for what so he
definitely felt like you are aware of
what to do in the position you had this
in your preparation did you feel like
your opponent was pondering potentially
continuing the game at any point
uh I guess you know he plays a line that
is
considered to be a combative line so I
guess he's not willing to make a quick
draw or repetition but I think he
understood that I know this position
better than him so that's why maybe he
decided to settle for a draw you've
played so many top Elite level events
throughout your career but this is your
first US championships do you have any
butterflies
ah it's wonderful you know that this uh
you know it's like old-fashioned 14
players I really love this and there is
this kind of uh you know feeling like as
the French say
espritical you know that everybody is
here for one purpose and it's it's one
big family of chess players I really
love that it's a Well national title on
the line so definitely a big event now
let's talk about this game you guys were
mentioning this one between in Sam and
Ray Robson how do you assess this one
this is a well-known line and this is
the old-fashioned way of playing with
black
I think kramnik played like this with
black but he tried to play Knight of 896
early on I think on move 10 line is F6
Knight F3
and then I think Knight f8 something
like this but the general consensus
consensus of this variation is that
although the computer is fine he thinks
black is okay but it's much easier to
play with white I mean at least that's
what
um
I think and that's what I think some of
my colleagues think what are the plans
for both sides I think white normally
puts the queen on C3 early on maybe even
before
maybe here something like that and then
you try to play C4 you know okay four or
K1
and queen A3 eventually and take on A6
and check sacrifice
that's pretty straightforward yeah yeah
just three exemplify let's put a couple
of moves because it's quite a risk
and of course I'm making very bad moves
for it black obviously but this is quite
nice group takes A6 take on A6 Queen
takes A6 yeah you know in this position
you want to intimidate black into taking
only three and then once you you take ft
key
then let's say here Bishop takes yeah
yeah you can take I mean maybe not here
because the pawn is not on before yet
maybe here you'll capture with the
Knight but if you were to have the
bottom g8b4 yeah yeah I think you take
you can take ft key and Knight A5 is
coming
I mean there's always some sacrifices
yeah yeah you're trying to get this uh
you know even 985 Knight d395 this type
of ideas and it doesn't seem like black
can break through on the Kingston no no
it's it's a rather passive position for
black so I
I think Ray uh maybe didn't expect this
opening so he he tries to play something
uh very solid
um but it's not the type of solid that I
like myself and how would black uh go
along and try to defend this position or
at least try to create let's say his
counter chances on the king side I think
he has to at some point go for F5 I mean
he has to play some Rook G8 G4
you know and then try to play F5 and
kind of you know use this h3g3 you know
E4 and try to give the queen involved in
the game
excellent well thank you very much uh
Levon and just to not to interrupt you
but this game has finished in a draw
between a wonder and Wesley so
Levon uh congratulations on a successful
start to the US Championship you still
have plenty of games left we'll see you
in the future rounds thank you and Lavon
I don't want to put too much pressure on
you but you are my choice to win the
event so just you are interested
he's not trying to put too much pressure
too much I will not disappoint you yes
sir thank you that's what I wanted to
hear that's what I wanted to hear uh
turning our attention quickly uh to the
game between Bobby and Lanier for for a
moment we left it just at these this
moment Queen E3 we were thinking about
D4 C5 it was an intriguing idea boom
Bobby said Knight to B3 I'm attacking
both the B6 and the C5 Pawn what are you
gonna do about it Lanier said well I'm
going to protect my pawn and I'm going
to follow up with the move d4 if Abby
said just not so fast I'm going to put a
little pressure on this Pawn on A5 as
well and also if D4 Knight D4 yes as
possible
[Laughter]
nice uh nice catch there Anastasia it's
the uh the pin means uh you you can't
capture the Knight so Queen B6 and uh no
give me the pawns but let me protect the
pawns is Bishop E6 Bishop E7 black just
wants to complete his development and
again a lot of things might be happening
with f4f5 but let's turn to uh Christian
as we have more guests in studio
Christian thank you Yasser we are indeed
with the 2021 US Open Champion Alex
leneron Alex welcome back to St Louis we
did analyze your game with Levon but
tell us what you saw from your
perspective in this game
yeah
um well um so as you could see with the
opening choice I sort of went for a
pretty interesting fight like I played a
nice Solani usually when you play an
Iceland it's like going to be a three
result game so obviously I feel very bad
that the game ended the way it did like
that was certainly not my intention to
uh do it like that because
um you know I
you know it's
like I I don't I don't remember the last
time I had a a game like this where I
had to make a draw uh where I ended up
making a draw by repetition as early as
like before move 20.
um how did you make that decision
to stop the game at that point and go
Knight F3 yeah so if we go back to
Bishop C2 Knight A5 so but when when I
played so first of all um if we go back
to the position after 1283
um it's if I remember correctly Lavon
had a game with black
um after Bishop takes C3 he did against
Peralta yes B Tech C3 Rook C8 and he won
that game and it's a fight
um and I think I had an improvement
there so I was gonna hopefully try to
play that position
um so you have this position in your
preparation this morning yes excellent
um but he surprised you with this one
he's surprised with Bishop he sell and
now I believe I had that in my notes and
I believe I analyzed this but the thing
is the position is so unusual there are
like many setups for black it's just
like one of these positions that's hard
to completely analyze till the end
um but I still thought I had a
reasonable enough knowledge and that's a
career relatively rare line that I
thought maybe Lavon wouldn't be quite as
familiar with
um I mean I don't remember if Bishop C2
exactly was in my notes but I thought
it's a pretty logical move and then here
he played Knight A5 and I don't really
recall on this exact position in my
notes but result 95 is the most logical
move but then I saw he can play Knight
C6 and I was like okay at the worst case
scenario I can play Knight F3 and you
know then look for something better
later on not not necessarily make a
drawer just yet but at least see what he
does maybe he'll want to play for a win
also because certainly black I didn't
think black absolutely had to play
Knight A5 I thought he can also consider
taking a risk and there's only some yeah
playing other moves
exactly and it's not clear that they're
like you know that much worse for black
or anything like that so so I thought
okay 95 95 seemed like the most logical
move and I played it relatively quickly
maybe about five minutes and then he
played Knight C6 quite quickly so I
thought well I wasn't sure if it's
preparation or not during the game I
thought like maybe he's he just thinks
it's the most logical move but I thought
it's possible it's preparation but I
wasn't sure so here I really had a
pretty deep think I tried to see if I
can I think originally I wanted to play
something like Bishop E3 maybe but then
I just didn't like it so much I thought
Rook C8 and I didn't really see what my
next move is
um I also considered if we go back
instead of Bishop E3 I consider taking
and then uh ideas like Queen D3 or
rookie 3 but in none of the positions I
thought I'm better I thought if anyone
is better it's black because she got a
chance to exchange a pair of minor
pieces in iqp and normally that's
something that favors the side playing
against iqp so I thought well and at
this point I was also burning time so I
thought at this point I'm playing a
slightly worse position unclear position
maybe my opponent is in prep and I have
to make I'm the one who has to make
tough decisions and I'm not even sure
what move I'm supposed to play so it's
like you know whether I have a drawing
hand or not be thinking about this
position a lot anyway so at this point
I'm falling behind the clock 10 20
minutes and you know so I decided to
play uh Knight F3 definitely feels like
and practical decision yeah and then so
I repeated once right and then he and
then I thought well also it wouldn't be
uh okay so he repeated one Knight F3
Knight A5 right
um yeah yeah and then here of course I
thought well what other options I had in
this position I thought maybe bishop G5
I thought maybe bishop F4 but yeah none
of the lines I really liked all that
much and again I was already 20 minutes
behind on the clock so I thought well
okay I have to make a move because at
this point what if he decides like if I
can't go down like
like an hour on the clock because if you
go 95 96 then he can go Rook C8 yeah
exactly or not Rook C8 right away
exactly so I can't be irresponsible and
fall behind too much in the clock so I
have to make a move relatively quickly
so I okay I played 95 and I was hoping
maybe I'll give myself one last attempt
to really go deep and try to find
something there like if maybe something
opens up a miracle happens but you know
then you know if we go back to 96 yeah
so here I was considering all sorts of
ideas right again Knight C6 I was trying
to calculate queen of three you know I
was I was trying to look at all sir
queen of three you can put it on the
board but I thought Rook C8 you know or
queen C8 maybe which is the best move in
the position yeah actually it seems like
black is starting to take over yeah and
like every trial was looking at like at
the best I thought the position is
unclear and keep in mind there's a
Chance season prep and he's ahead on the
clock so I thought okay at this point it
would just be irresponsible for me to
actually play the game game on because
yeah at this point I'm just playing
clearly in not equal terms I'm pretty
sure at this point against any GM I'll
just make a draw here because it's uh
yeah it's just one of these positions
where it's clear that I have to take a
pretty big risk if I want to play on so
I mean I feel very bad I feel very sorry
for the fans that they had to see a game
like that but yeah at this point I
thought of just
you know it would be very irresponsible
for me to keep playing the game it's a
long event and I do believe that this
was the practical decision Alex will see
you in the next games thank you
thank you indeed Alex a big surprise
after Lavon came on and very
authoritatively Anastasia explained to
us that in such positions Sam Shanklin
will go rook 8-4 and queen uh C3 and
Rook A1 and Checkmate brilliantly yeah
okay very nice sacrifice on A6 and what
does Sam do no
[Laughter]
commentators curse thank you Lavon I
mean rescued us uh Rook D1 well that
pretty much says I have one idea in mind
and that is to make a central break with
D4 whether that's prepared by Knight
takes B6 or queen C3 Rook A1 to D1 if
you give me 10 options I would never get
this right I mean and furthermore if I
gave you the exact position right now on
the board and if you decide excited to
play the move Rook A1 Maybe
why
you didn't you know we did that we had
these mixed doubles competitions where
sometimes the two players were in
opposition to one another they they
sabotaged their own ideas but Rook D1 uh
quite remarkable and once more we have a
guest in studio with Christian we do
indeed we are we the defending Champion
2021 Champion Wesley so Wesley welcome
back uh to the studio tell us a bit how
did you leave this first round at the US
chess championships
um well I'm
slightly disappointed obviously not to
get the game but at the same time it's a
long tournament also I remember uh I
think this is my seventh youth
Championship if I'm correct
played one online also like uh it's
always a tough tournament and like last
year remember I had difficult game with
black against Jeffrey made the solid
draw and then things went well in the
tournament
um so
it actually started thinking after move
one after his move E4 and yasu was a bit
confused why we took like a minute and a
half to play E5 why why'd you do that oh
yeah well good question well actually I
was just looking at some of the boards
because there was a long line the day on
the scanners so like Fabi was a few
minutes late because he was in line I
think some other players
so so it had nothing to do with us Jeff
I just also wanted to see like other
openings like Darius were explaining the
slab against Jefferson when he normally
doesn't and also the Neiman game with
the Knights theater Bishop F4 so I was
just waiting to see also I thought we'd
get another better of
a theoretical battle in the linear game
versus linear but but yeah that's a good
chance because
um
actually I wonder told me he's in
studying in the University of Chicago
right now so he's missed three weeks of
school and he told me it's a bit Rusty
but I didn't know this before the game
so
um in hindsight maybe I should have
considered playing other openings such
as the Sicilian but I wonder if a
predominantly E4 player and I played my
usual opening but um obviously when
you're playing some a lower rated player
I mean very strong but lower rated uh
they it could happen that they would be
happy to to get a draw and uh you know
getting out there with black for me is
also not such a bad deal but uh I feel
that was the case in this game given the
opening okay in hindsight maybe I should
have played another opening because a
Wonder hasn't played a lot of Chess
recently you know how being a college
student feels like you've been a college
student once yeah it can it can be a
professional player and a college
student it means too much classes and
your professors don't know anything
about you maybe nowadays they do but
back then you know so you guys went into
this super long line Bishop to D2 you
played it as white did not surprise you
right yeah I played this white a couple
times against Magnus
um
also
well the problem is I wonder is very
good in the opening like obviously today
he came extremely well prepared so when
he played Bishop dito I started thinking
like to play something else
or to go for this long line with Bishop
takes theater and the fight is the first
round you know uh wasn't
ex of course I didn't predict that he
would go for this line before before the
game but I had such a narrow opening a
piratory that you know it's not a
surprise when someone says something new
um the funny part was I played this
position twice with white against Magnus
and both games I got the worst position
so
[Laughter]
but this game is a well-known draw
um but in any case it's just the first
round and this U.S Championship is
extremely long it's almost as long as or
it's actually as long as why can't they
speak to me about that for a second you
mentioned at the beginning of the
interview that this new format with 14
players instead of 12 players is going
to be different what do you mean by that
uh well there's two more days right
there's two more games uh normally these
days I think an average classical term
is around 10 days long I think 13 games
is a bit too long uh also now you you
have more lower rated players than than
last year
uh I mean it's fine but you have to like
conserve your energy preserve your
energy because you know uh people
question why make every draws and stuff
but you have to realize that we play
every single day and you also prepare
beforehand
um so I think like 11 games is long
enough for this Championship but this
year is an exception I've actually
talked to James Star John yesterday
who's one of the inductees
in the Hall of Fame
and he told me in the old days US
championships last 16 games
old school yeah yeah but but they didn't
have a to prepare with a computer in
those days and uh looking without
looking at the electronics before game
can be very tiring Wesley
congratulations a smooth start for you
still plenty of games to go we'll let
you rest yeah I think also like I played
the online a couple days ago against
Jefferson so oh yeah that was a big
battle yeah that was awesome yeah in the
playoffs yeah I got very lucky but uh
um
no but yeah one day at a time one day at
a time thank you very much Wesley thank
you Wesley uh just a quick comment and
maybe you could follow up with a comment
of your own yesterday at the opening
ceremony I saw you taking uh pictures
with an inductee Eugene
you look like uh you were really
enjoying uh being with eugeno and uh
honoring him and as he was inducted at
World Chess Hall of Fame your thoughts
about Eugene OR getting into the World
Chess Hall of Fame is a good friend of
mine I mean obviously we haven't
uh talk to each other in a long time but
he was one of the few people who
supported me a lot when I switched
federations and he's one of my not
officially my chess coach but it's one
of my uh very early coaches
uh he was the official team coach in the
2003 World deal and also I think in 2004
and 2005
so he's he was one of the players that I
really look up to on learning Jeff and
he's helped me a lot I've given me
plenty of advice and
giving me chess books when I was young
so he's
I'm really thankful he's one of the most
decent man in chess that you could look
after and he's also played 22 Olympians
if if I'm correct which is an insane
amount I I think he's a very talented
player and I think he could have gone
farther if he maybe switch federations
like
but uh but yeah he meant I've known him
and his wife for a long time now and
they're gonna be here for they're gonna
be touring the United States for for a
few days and uh maybe I think we're
we're planning to have dinner with them
one night maybe maybe tonight because I
finish very early but uh but certainly
he's a legend first Asian Grandmaster uh
and he's also one of the seconds of
Bobby Fisher in the 1992 match
uh so he's uh he's overall a great guy
and I think he still plays chess very
well it's three things around 24.50
thank you for those kind words
absolutely Eugene a really really a
chess Legend and I I known him since the
80s and uh always a good guy good guy to
be around exactly and I think for for
our followers who missed the opening
ceremony it would be nice if you would
will go to a Saint Louis chess club
YouTube channel and check the opening
ceremony and you can see the speech of
Tori and actually he addressed to at one
point to Wesley so he he reminded
everyone that he became a 9 LX champion
and 60 world champion yes and uh
something he could on the two
exactly so it was interesting speech and
um our short speech by Eugene very much
I wanted to turn our attention to this
game between ashrita and Alice Lee and
if you like chaos well check out these
next few moves as a G6 well uh once we
saw Rook G1 we can anticipate that
srithra is ready to put her either on
the queen side or in the center and so
it's just like let's blow up the king
size position exactly it takes and a
knight G5 that's really throwing down
the gauntlet uh as ideas of uh Knight
takes H7 for example in the air takes on
G6 and just this looks really
promising attack for white before
ashrita played the move G6 I had it in
mind again you know the heroic side of
me you know like I can sacrifice other
people's pieces better than they can
Bishop takes H7 check Knight takes H7 G6
don't forget that there's a bishop
lurking on this long diagonal so
something like this takes takes takes
Bishop here you're almost
instinctively your eyes should be drawn
like 95. exactly exactly and again bang
bang bang and let's go it seems to me
that Alice Lee has got to come up with
some really uh good stuff here uh
Christian as she's under a lot of
pressure oh absolutely and actually she
missed a golden opportunity ashrita that
is the line that you were just showing
with Bishop takes H7 that was the key
move congratulations
the U.S chess champion for so many uh
years after Bishop takes H7 Knight takes
H7 once again you have to sacrifice
another piece knight takes B5 you
identified the factors that need to be
played uh playing an important role in
an active role in the position in order
for your attack as wide to be successful
Knight takes B5 a takes B5 and now
finally that you have so much pressure
or after this move G6 on the G file is
going to be extremely difficult for
black to react successfully and defend
this position first of all if you just
take on G6 after Queen takes G6 there is
no way you will be able to defend this
Pawn on G7 you can go when F6 is not
possible maybe Queen F6 is no longer
possible and actually that's why you
start with Knight takes D5 you can go G6
if you don't give the Knight first G6 F
takes G6 and now Queen takes G6 this is
actually bad because Queen to F6
finishes a White's attack in one move
and actually right now you're much worse
as white you're just a piece down I'm
going to be able to close this diagonal
after the move E5 in the future you
don't have time to put enough pressure
on my position you have to start by
giving up another piece with Knight
takes B5 I think this is what a srita
missed she probably saw Bishop takes H7
she saw G6 but she did not consider this
idea of sacrificing another piece with
Knight takes B5 once again it's easy
when it's not your pieces but when you
are facing these opportunities and these
decisions is not as easy to make the
precise Choice she missed it and right
now actually Alice is in a pretty decent
position after G6 after hd6 Knight to G5
the attack still looks visually vicious
but is not as powerful why what do you
play here yeah exactly I I'm all ears it
looks scary oh absolutely but what if I
go H6 just challenging just challenging
this Knight on G5 with a move and again
this is not an easy move to make what
I'm trying to make is create a cocoon
around my king right if you go backwards
then I go G5 I close things up and then
the position is fine for black right
sure you're not going to do that if
you're challenged with the move H6 right
now you just have to sacrifice something
you have to sacrifice something either
with Knight to F7 or even take on G6 and
open up the H file and hope that you're
going to be able to deliver the
Checkmate it's not going to be as easy
big decision right now coming for early
sleep will she find H6 because if she
doesn't well the position it does look
extremely scary can we go down the the
rabbit hole for just a moment yeah
you don't want to take on G6 that's a
Checkmate in two moves yeah Queen takes
G6 King D7 Queen G7 that's a Checkmate
you don't want to do that
what you do want is not King to G8
because after Bishop takes E8 Queen
takes C8 I'm going to once again open up
that right Knight takes B5
that's over right right it takes B5 or
Knight to E4 even stronger than Knight
takes B5 but what you can do
is go King to E7 okay I only need a
couple of moves to hide my king right so
what do you do next if you do take on E8
I'm going to take back with the queen
right and that's going to open up after
Rook hd7 the Escape Square on d8 I'm
still alive and Black's position in fact
is quite good right now two pieces
your attack is not going anywhere
anymore and it's so much more difficult
to open up the position on the queen
side right I have such a nice structure
of Pawns that's defending my king so the
King on d8 right now pre-safe but it's
too playable I think playable absolutely
absolutely playable this is going to be
a game if we end up in this situation
I don't think we we will of course H6
just the start of it is so scary right
because you're seeing so many pieces
swarming around your king so many things
that you could miss in the position and
just get checkmated right so it's a
scary situation for young Alice Lee the
youngest competitor in all of the US
chess championships she's only 12 years
of age oh it's well and you play in U.S
Championship I mean what a what an honor
exactly no I mean my goodness at 12
years old I started yeah you know never
mind being invited to the Washington
State Championship or the U.S
Championship no way the answer you
played in 86 the first one the first U.S
Championship
was in
1979. how old were you at that time 19
19 1861 yes yes yes I the first time I
wanted I would yeah I think it's the
first time I with Walter Brown but
Knight F7 I I mean again this position
it's one of those thing I mean you're
looking at it you're just you're just
salivating you're ready to capture on G6
you're ready to capture on H7 and it
just it it's kind of a a moment where
you just kind of get Frozen uh because
it's you know you want to believe you
can defend the position after H7 H6 but
it's really easy to convince yourself
that your King's not going to escape
like you know mentally if you see this
position it's not possible and she
didn't play H6 right she played b b C4
takes C4
so okay so this
okay wait a minute now we start
holy smokes it doesn't change as much
you can still do the same thing so B
takes C4 B takes C4 most likely is going
to be the move right and now once again
H6 is a possibility
okay but in this case then you mentioned
that Black's King got to d8 in that two
pieces versus Rook you've actually maybe
opened up the queen size you did you did
and that's why probably is slightly
worse than the version with the pawns on
B5 and BC
wow okay we'll keep our eye on this I
wanted to quickly go to a marquee
matchup between tatev and Arena Crush
because uh to my eyes when we left it I
thought Arena was getting her attack in
there first and well with this move a
four A5 A4 that seems to be the case for
some reason I really wanted black to
include the move Queen C7 maybe not only
to get off the D file but just you know
in principle the queen on C7 is a great
Square you know you're just kind of
covering the C file Knight C6 ideas she
went A4 right away A3 and we're up to
date with a play here the fact that
tataf is having to react on the queen
side so early not a good sign I would
assume
moves like well it frankly takes on A3
then you take with the Knight probably
right yeah it kind of helps a little bit
but not Queen A5 or maybe just even
ignoring this how how big a threat is a
b probably it's a big threat
um
it feels like arena is in the driver's
seat here uh just not too sure by how
much uh Christian back over to you what
do you think about this position very uh
complex battle in this one it does feel
practically and Visually in the position
that perhaps black is ahead
but despite of all of that your Pawn on
A4 is still quite a weakness so if I
manage as white to exchange some pieces
for example B takes A3 Knight takes A3
let's say Bishop takes D4 Rook takes D4
and you go Bishop to D7 right slowly but
surely it does feel like I'm exchanging
some pieces in the position and
potentially getting closer and closer to
an end game this is what I want to see
from the player with the white pieces I
want to see her direct the game towards
an end game because if we do get there
you have so many things to worry about
as black you have the pawn on D6 which
is surely going to be a very difficult
uh weakness to defend you have the pawn
on A4 which is a bit overextended this
is the other side of the coin uh you
push your pawns you try to Checkmate the
white king but if I manage to tame the
position as white well unfortunately
your opponents are going to be
overextended and I'm going to be able to
pick them up especially in the end game
when I can activate my pieces easily
with the move such as Rook 2 D4 Swinging
The Rook around and basically once we
reach that point it's going to be the
differentiator the big differentiator in
the position is going to be who's going
to have the more active pieces and the
way I see it this Rook on D4 is
definitely if you compare it with the
Rook on A8 in a potential end game is
going to be much more active with the
other Rook swinging to D1 and putting a
lot of pressure on D6 this is the dream
right for white so this is what I'm
seeing right now black does have to find
a way to keep the pieces on the board
depend upon on D6 because you know the
pressure is coming so I don't know
sure from a practical perspective maybe
you're close to opening at the king's
position on the Queen's side the engine
is saying zero zero zero
I don't know who to give it to uh this
one I have to say still a very complex
battle I'm also looking at the time 49
minutes for Irena only 32 minutes for
tatev and uh if she does fall under an
attack on the queen side that time a
difference potentially will be deadly so
she has to keep an eye on her clock
management thank you Christian for that
and of course we we want to send a big
shout out to our audience of course
thank you thank you so much for joining
us but also I want to give our audience
an opportunity to join the conversation
and send us tweets how can they do that
uh Anastasia yeah you can always follow
first of all our social media okay so
you can do it yes of course subscribe
also in Instagram and in Twitter and at
Facebook and please ask the questions in
our Twitter account St Louis chess club
use the hashtag cheerschamps right and
then you will get to us and you can
we'll be able to ask questions the best
ones will be picked up by the team and
we will see them on the screen sounds
good uh turning our attention to begum's
position against uh Sophie this is a a
very typical looking
open
Sicilian almost a carer's attack you
might say with Upon A G4 except for one
detail which is rather confounding and
that detail is this bishop on G6 you put
the bishop on C8 everybody says well
this is absolutely normal and this last
move by uh begum right here uh Queen
back to D2 to my eyes that's a very
clear signal I want to play F4 and F5
trapping the bishop why did she Retreat
the queen and not play F4 right away
well she was probably worried that after
E5
takes takes not only is the bishop not
trapped but the Knight has a nice Square
on E5 I mean there are other
considerations going on here but that
was why uh began played Queen back to D2
pardon me nice reflector
some ideas F4 F5 that's a that Bishop
could suddenly which is a great
defensive piece find itself trapped
we'll keep an eye on that one and uh
Christian uh What uh what positions in
this round one of God you're right well
I was actually checking the Fabiano
versus leniergie the big matchup in the
open section because I have to say in
actually Wesley when he came in he saw
me analyzing this position and he
immediately said oh black is better
right and yes black in this position
actually it's better not only that but
after King to H1 the move played by
Fabiano the engine is giving black a
decisive Advantage wow decisive event
guys minus 1.8 with the simple move
Bishop to E7 the thing is it's going to
be very difficult to get your attack
going what it says is that after F4 I'm
just simply going to block you on the
light squares with the move Bishop to F5
there is no way your knight is already a
bit too far away from the action you
would love to get it let's say to F3 and
then H4 or G5 try to put some pressure
you cannot do that anymore your knight
is on B3 far away from the action you
can pick up pick up a pawn if you want
but that's not going to help you much
because I'm just simply going to go
castle and once again once your Dynamic
play gets infused in the position with
the move d4 Queen to C4 and now Rook to
B8 I have so much compensation for your
extra pawn and once I manage to get this
Queen off the C4 rank of the C4 Square
I'm going to be able to push C4 myself
kick the Knight away everything is just
going to be kicked backwards and at some
point I'm just simply going to start
picking up pause B2 is going to fall
your a pawn is uh going to be in grave
Danger and after that once I get to the
pawn on B2 your C2 Pawn is also going to
be in grave danger not only that but you
don't have a lot of squares for your
pieces this is what I'm worried about
for White's position
this is uh the situation right now that
we have King to H1 we're waiting for
linear to make a decision Fabiano only
with a five minute advantage on the
clock so definitely after the opening
phase uh phased out right now we're
seeing Lanier picking up the pace and
putting some pressure with the black
pieces in this game against Fabiano
carono intriguing and also very
intriguing is the game we were following
just a moment ago between ashrita and
Alice after B5 takes C4 B take C4 guess
what uh Alice picked up the gauntlet and
said what are you gonna do and she
played the move H7 H6 and well srita
understood if that she just makes a
simple Retreat well after G6 G5 the king
side gets shut down and black gets the
Tempe she needs to cover her King so in
for a penny in for a pound Knight F7
King takes F7 Bishop takes G6 check on
the board and and the players are likely
to follow that variation which went King
E7 Bishop takes the king gets on its
sneakers and goes for a run
and what happens from here different
position no bones on B5 and B3 right so
probably better for white maybe we can
do something here going B3 maybe
sometimes it's not immediately no
Knights if I was coming so right
something
to do something first exactly but the
the idea that because the Pawns of the
bee pawns are gone
putting a rook on B1 or something like
that and uh
well it was it was the signature line
only time will tell us to what is going
to happen in this uh position but what
other games uh have caught your
attention uh Christian trademark death
yes sir trade my name hey the patent's
pending on my name please
Jeffrey versus uh Darius this one is
very interesting uh I'm looking at the
position and I see a big difference in
this case and that is not only the fact
that white has tremendous space
advantage on the queen side but also
this weakness the pawn on A5 this is a
big problem in the position and I don't
actually see a good way for black to
hold on uh to that you're going to have
to swing
um this bishop back to d8 this Rook 2 A8
and basically uh cement and confirm all
your pieces to the defense of the Pawn
on A5 once you do that as white I'm
going to have the option of potentially
breaking in the center with the move E4
I see this position as one for two
results either a draw if I don't manage
to break through with the white pieces
or just a win for white there's just too
much passivity in Black's position to
give him any uh big chances of
potentially winning this one so Jeffrey
Sean Anastasia speak definitely in
favorable situation right now let's see
well just our results uh so far no
results in the ladies the ladies are
Fighters but we've got two uh two draws
in the open section as uh defending
Champion Wesley so yes
those are the two draws that we're
discussing and a lot of chaos going on
in the other games especially in those
Mark D matchups between Shanklin Ray
Robson Bobby and Lanier and we're just
going to take a commercial break and
reset ourselves and we'll see on the
other side
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the World Chess Hall of Fame in St Louis
is nothing you'd expect and everything
you love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the World
Chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
can you hear it it's the sound of Hope
and health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities it sounds
like life and it's what you hear when
you really listen
can you hear it
it's the sound of Hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
with care
and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
Ascension
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back to US championships
here we are with Joseph serovan in Saint
Louis chess club following Direction I
was about to say here we are with
Anastasia following all the action but
yes indeed we are at the opening round
of round one of the U.S championships
and we're going to do a quick uh Trip
Around the Horn we're going to start
with the uh women's championships and uh
just bringing up the game between Anna
and Jennifer Jennifer uh by the way is
my choice along with varusian I got a
great support behind me as unfortunately
game is rather balanced I'm seeing four
versus four bishop and knight uh maybe
maybe slightly better for Anna she has
the first chance to take this uh open
file open file with Rook C1 but I do
feel a balance this is one of those
imbalance games between Arena and Tata
heavyweight matchup between these two
veterans who have played so many U.S
championships together with Arena
winning so many amazing can you imagine
yes sir I mean you can't actually
imagine but still it's a lot d65 it
looks like Arena
is the first to get in an attack but on
the other hand this Pawn on A4 of the
attack misses it smart could potentially
Round Up This pawn and well take it to
an advantage I like this D5 move
actually remember we were talking the D6
is a little bit it's a weak Pawn so
absolutely Irina decided just to get rid
of it and play D5 which is typical idea
and I mean now it's interesting what
white will do I mean you don't want to
take it probably or exactly you don't
want to take it because like I I would
have I would think that something like
this is more or less a dream for black
in the sense that a lot of lines have
been opened up against whites King
whereas well your your light years away
from generating a threat against black
skin it is a pawn uh and we'll keep an
eye on this one uh the game between uh
Sabina and Naji this is kind of funny
for me because both players cons
inspired to trade nothing
everything is still on the board the
pods the pieces everything uh the only
difference though is the clock times
that's a huge difference on the clock
time I'll spot you 30 minutes on the
clock if you give me space I'm not sure
that's a good deal I say queen of
seventh fret this is the only thing I
can understand in this position
needs to let's say we defend it
just choosing one of two moves maybe
well maybe even three moves working
paper Rook E7 Queen he said and well it
is a kind of a king's Indian Czech
benoni I like white space but uh but
what to do with it exactly I mean you
created this one thread and what is next
like G4 you cannot play at night we'll
go to F4 that would be uh what we would
call a positional dollar yeah that night
on F4 is very good uh so it will take
you a while maybe you'll have to bring
the bishop back to C1 if you want to
play G4 uh intriguing game uh Megan
Pardon Me versus Rochelle
even in terms of ponds of material but I
do like the two Bishops for uh Rochelle
open position write them in two Bishops
maybe it can play some role later on in
the game no question about it okay this
is the the players have followed our
main line of play
um Alice had to get on her running shoes
with the king and the King has
jettisoned uh to the queen side two
pieces for a rook uh this is really
double edged I kind of like the two
pieces uh the king looks pretty darn
safe once I get to C7 I understand this
Rook on the seventh it's powerful but
there's a pawn hanging on H5 right Alice
has got uh
her pluses and then this open Sicilian
between begum and Sophie this last move
by begum A5
I'd be reluctant to just remove the
Knight for a moment maybe something like
Queen C7 if I can get away with that
without losing material I'd much rather
play a move like Queen C7 in this
position keep an eye on this one
fights all across the board I want to
say uh good for us good for the
followers exactly right
we have the finally Talia versus ruyang
I always like these positions for black
uh I was playing Queens game but
declined most of my career these threats
of Bishop takes H3 but most especially
simply the move Rook to E5 followed by
Rook to E8 and just this idea that I get
to attack without having sacrificed
anything maybe we'll induce white to
play a move not what you really want to
do uh F2 F4 given up the C4 right
exactly forever but these attacks can be
really dangerous like if you just kind
of make a a no a move like this you
better be better be ready to analyze the
ramifications of a bishop takes probably
you have f2f4 here so I'm being a little
bit too aggressive yes sir heroic that's
the word of the day
but uh Rook E8 and again I can play
these these kind of games in my sleep
Rook to G5 and let's go going
over I just got to go over to the open
section we'll start with the fact that
we have two draws and actually let me
just bring up the game of Sam and elshon
Bishops of opposite colors means that
the one who will find a way to create
some attack on the king
can have another hand but I'm not sure
it's easy to do or not in this position
I must say it looks very very balanced
accessories hanging C3 is hanging maybe
it's time just to make a trade uh invite
Queen takes C3 take this F7 Pawn okay uh
looks balanced let's jump to this game
actually is a very nice game between uh
Christopher and Hans
um it fell like with thanks to the two
Bishops especially but also to the fact
that they're just space that Hans uh was
to be preferred and I think these last
move a few moves bear that out it's
black who is
H4 it can become really unpleasant for
white and this Knight on the one night
she told they look all passive right
right if you just look at White's pieces
they're on the first three ranks okay
it's not like blacks pieces are on for
D3 and everything else but uh just the
fact that black is more flexible black
is the one who has opportunities with G5
and H4 makes me think that uh Hans is
for Choice Jeffrey Sean well let me see
here who pricked Jeffrey oh I understand
you got some skin in this one this was
the game that Christian was talking
about with just this idea that the pawn
on A5 was a kind of a sore
weakness and that white is going to
attack this with as many pieces yes he
possibly can again I don't know if you
call it the same way
how am I supposed to say Allah kind in
Russian in Russian yes I mean we say I
love him but I think recently everybody
kind of goes to a legend yes so I heard
that this is the correct way but we
still can discuss it okay okay
uh Sam oh wow okay Sam Shanklin Ray
Robson what a game we've got here this
Pawn on H3
um Edward Beaufort would call this Pawn
as like being a snake wrapped around
your neck it's always there these
backrank Checkmate threats I think Rey
has done well to get this position I
would say three results and finally
another Marquee matchup Fabi versus
Lanier when we left it Christian was
saying uh Lanier all the way that linear
with his two Bishops uh has advantages
that's still the case uh Christian
absolutely uh and you guys gave an
amazing round down and you started off
with this game if I'm not mistaken Sam
versus elshon and you said it's complex
actually Sam is completely winning wow
yes with the white pieces it's all about
this Square F7 and you guys were
pointing out that's where F7 quite
frequently after Queen 24 you're pretty
much busted at this point you're going
to lose at least a pawn you cannot take
on C3 you don't have time to do that
because after root takes D7 there's so
much pressure on F7 and it's all about
the back rank checkmates if you take
take the bishop you cannot take the
bishop because of Queen to E8 or queen
to C8 which are going to deliver the
Checkmate so that's not possible what I
think he wanted after their Queen to A4
is to go D5 the problem is when you look
at the position now you start realizing
that you still have some back rank
problems after Queen takes A5 you cannot
take the respawn C8 because Queen takes
d8 Bishop takes d8 Rook takes d8 and
that's going to be game over as well
Queen 38 that's a Checkmate so you
cannot do that Queen to A4 has been
played on the board what shocks me I
have to say is the fact that elshon has
47 minutes a losing position against 12
minutes for Sam Savion we know Sam can
get into time travel situations but
right now the way I see this position is
a bit too easy to play White I have a
clear plan that is to focus on your
weaknesses and you have a lot of them
corn on F7 Pawn on A5 Pawn on D7 Pawn on
C5 all of them can be considered
weaknesses also if you go something like
Queen to C7 Queen to B3 D6 let's say
there's another weakness s in the
position that is the B file and with
your last couple of moves especially
this one after Rook to D1 Rook to d8 now
you finally give me uh the opportunity
to take advantage of the fact that I can
double my pieces with Tempo on the B
file Queen to B3 you have defend F7 with
D6 now I can go Rook to B1 take
advantage of the fact that your Rook is
no longer on B8 and this might be
problematic and this is what we're
seeing right now in the position Queen
to C7 and Sam has the opportunity to not
only have the advantage of playing
against all the weaknesses that black
has in the position but also control the
only open file in the position the B
file
wow uh boy that's uh that's a cold shock
when I was thinking the opposite color
Bishops that the worst had passed there
was a weakness on the G3 but do you
remember I said that the one who wanted
to attack or create something maybe it
will be impossible but literally I
didn't know all this I just meant notice
that after move D5 which Christian
proposed maybe even Bishop D5 was
possible Bishop takes D5 but never
remember maybe we can check them
together remember queen Queen Seven he
said move D5
yes maybe now Bishop D5 definitely a
move that is definitely a move
across my mind yes why I don't think it
works as well is because I can take on
C3 right now you can pick up history I
think so because now you don't have the
root takes D7 with an attack on F7
interesting so I just wanted to check it
like it's tempting no it's very tempting
very very tempting takes D5 once you
realize that E8 there's an x-ray threat
on the E8 Square Bishop takes D5 is the
first thing that pops into your mind
Checkmate on the back rank but if I was
good enough yes Queen A5
well unfortunately for elshon elshon
found himself having this drop back
passively with the queen Rook D3 this is
a kind of a nice move although there was
something to recommend as Christians was
saying with Queen B3 but Rook D3 I find
these Rook lifts really nice depends the
pawn on C3 it Preps
Rook F3 and after the move G6 Alshon
playing quickly probably try hoping to
take advantage of Sam's uh clock there's
a clear strategy related to that right
but it's coming from uh elshon yeah
exactly but Rook F3 I'm assuming King G7
has to and something like Bishop D3 and
I'm looking at this queen
eyeballing along the lines here uh that
well this almost is play on one goal
actually it's not going to be elshon is
going to be playing the role of defender
on the board guys for for quite a while
here as he did Sam Savion did play the
move Bishop to D5 and usually these
types of position you also you'd love to
get in this h4h5 so definitely an
awkward position for
uh for uh
black and again Elsa uh he he's a very
very popular Grandmaster in Residence
here St Louis chess club transferred
from the Iranian Chess Federation I
um qualified by winning the U.S open was
it a held in Palm Springs this year or
was it held the u.so picked Palm Springs
California so welcome welcome elshon
and our own varusian made it there as
well and yeah he actually won a tie
breaks against Iliad nishnik yes so he
knocked Ilya out but at the same time I
think at that point he was already the
winner of the U.S Championship spot
because Ilya does not play for the U.S
Federation yeah so he qualified even
without winning that one but he did win
the US Open in that one quite an
interesting situation now guys let's
take a look at this game between
Christopher and Hans because this one is
really hitting up you were mentioning
that it does feel like you have more
space with black you have the
opportunity to potentially open up the
situation on the king side with the move
H4 this is exactly what we're seeing
from Hans Rook to h8 H5 F5 this is a bit
of a puzzling move to my eyes because
you do allow me the opportunity to go
Rook to E5 and this is a very typical
sacrifice we see this Rook to E5 land in
a lot of situations a lot of strategy
books have showed this exchange
sacrifice with the move to E5 you're
inviting black to take on E5 you would
love black to take on E5 Bishop takes E5
D takes C5 and finally my Knight has a
beautiful Landing Square on D4 Knight to
D4 that's going to be putting a lot of
pressure I have to say I'm liking
White's position nevertheless
black is not forced to take after Rook 2
E5 you can start focusing on other
avenues of attack either B4 and open
things up on the queen side or even the
move H4 and try to open up things on the
king side very complex situation you're
going to try to open things up fast on
one of the sides what I'm going to be
focusing on is putting a lot of pressure
on the e-file and at some point fine the
right moment to sacrifice The Exchange
after with Rook takes E6 after Rook to
E1 and then put a lot of pressure on D5
or potentially just Rook takes D5 after
Knight to E3 there's a lot of ways in
which I can find a way to sacrifice that
exchange now what I'm seeing after I
remove F5 big discrepancy on the clock
43 minutes for Christopher you only 11
minutes and a lot of moves to go until
we reach the time control at move 40 for
Hans Nema only 11 minutes and right now
15 moves to go for Hans this is going to
be a wild one a quick question for you
Christian because to my eyes the move F6
F5 is a move I'd really resist playing
not only because I lose a Tempo forget
about that but because I do weaken the
E5 Square
I I kind of lock in my own light squared
Bishop why didn't he play H4 H4 looks
like a very good name it's a good move
and I'm not 100 sure why he not played
that move H4 was F5 a mistake
a slight inaccuracy yes okay yes H4
would have uh uh a very good position
for black right but isn't this like a
forcing way of maybe just opening up the
H file not necessarily devastating by it
yeah it's not devastating the bishop is
protecting the Knight is protecting the
business squares of H1 and H2 but
the open file absolutely can I maybe one
idea like maybe a fire has maybe the
idea took place a knight on F6 and then
before I mean this
yes yes trip I found for the night maybe
for example rookie five for example
there yes uh rookie one and please take
a lot of time no we don't have time yes
so we have to go Bishop but also you
don't have time because the bishop takes
D5 but at some moment the D5 Pawn is
even before that Bishop yes okay yes
it's not really possible yes if Rook A5
you don't have this move I just said
that maybe he tries to bring his Knight
there but it seems like it's not easy
absolutely but Christopher has to play
rookie five yeah it's because if he
doesn't that's exactly what's going to
happen for example for example yeah okay
rookie too looks like a reasonable like
now 98
98.1 and Bishop F7 and Bishop F7 yes and
as you say uh
yeah he's on the board guys
yeah if you don't play okay five you
play rookie two so maybe this idea of F5
making the F Square available for the
night and but don't you make it to E4
right now after 98 yes well it was like
a psychological
um
moment that that Hans offered
Christopher do you want to sacrifice in
exchange
it's probably a good idea and it's
probably something you have to do
because if you don't do it a night swing
to E4 is just going to be dominating uh
Christopher declined sacrificing The
Exchange and after Rook E1 Bishop F7 I
think we're agreed this is simply no way
to stop 94.95 clear Advantage black
oh this could be uh interesting okay
Jeffrey okay not too much going on there
Sam Shanklin Ray Robson uh take us away
on that uh game uh Christian because I'm
thinking that Rey did wonderfully well
securing the pawn on H3 he did no
absolutely not only that he secured the
pawn on H3 but the worries White's
attack on on the queen side there's no
attack you're not going to play B5
you're not going to play C4 because
there's so much tension after you play
this move a D4 you cannot relieve that
by playing the move C4 you cannot
support your attack on the queen side so
it does feel like this is just play on
one goal black is potentially trying to
improve the position sure white is still
very very uh safe in his position due to
the fact that all the major Central
files are closed right now if we open
those then you might get in trouble if
this queen started landing around the
King on H1 so still safe for or wide
nevertheless it does feel like black has
the initiative and black is the only one
that can potentially win this game I
have to say mightily impressed with what
Ray Robson has done so far 14 minutes
for him 38 minutes for Sam Shanklin and
I have to say Sam doesn't look very
confident I think he realizes that he's
no longer in a better position he hoped
that he's going to be able to
potentially squeeze water out of the
stone in this type of structures but
right now he is the one on the receiving
end of that squeeze uh should Rey be
trying to improve the position with B7
B6 King B7 or should he be leaving the
queen side but how do you continue even
after that I don't know I was thinking
that B6 King B7 might end up let's just
say B6 King G1 let's just say yes and I
don't know if the king is better on F2
than H1 I was thinking if five maybe you
played for A5 you don't have to be
careful right because whenever you go
Rook A8 maybe I get ideas of D5 or D
takes E5
start getting excited by the open D file
open file um yeah yeah I just didn't I
mean it it looks like they're kind of in
a standoff exactly no progress for any
side something like this exactly and how
do I make a progress uh with black if I
feel that I'm better sure I can just
wait with the move Queen E8 but if I was
concretely saying you know this is the
last round and I have to qualify for a
world championship match how do I win
with black well do you play B6 and King
B7 and Away you go let's just jump to
the lady section for a second because
whoa I have uh did I get this right did
uh Rue Yang play like
or no we have a rule we do have F4
remember I was saying the that The Rook
um
the uh Rover I was coming yes yeah yeah
provoked F4 so I assume we're gonna draw
back and now there is a drawback for the
move F2 F4 does mean that there's a
backward Pawn on E3 uh so tell you maybe
just on the slightly worse position here
and I wanted to actually I really wanted
to jump to the game of tata for a second
because I thought that this held the
most excitement and let's see what
happened after the move D5 we left it
here she took the pawn yes
[Laughter]
Bishop to A6 uh Queen F3 Queen B4 well
that's a straight double attack exactly
E4 on and before orange Danger
this looks promising for white here if I
have to make a move like Bishop B3 first
of all I'm not particularly for white
peace or for black but suddenly this
Knight has got gorgeous squares
um
oh my gosh no I'm saying that Queen F3
just the position on the board that I'm
seeing and it's not updated move Bishop
b3's on the board yeah Bishop is three
years I thought maybe she could trade
the Queens try
um but okay it looks like artificial
even Queen E4 is possible yes agreed and
I like it uh it looks to me like not
only has
Irina won her Pond back after D5 takes
E4 she's won it with interest no
absolutely and that's exactly how the
engines evaluate this position as well
we were discussing many minutes ago
maybe half an hour to an hour ago that
white should probably try to exchange
the Queens the problem is right now in
final position if you go Queen to C3 I'm
going to take on C3 I can do that and
after B takes C3 you have the double
pawns that's not a good structure also
if you try to support the push of those
pawns with the move C4 or is the Knight
on A3 going probably nowhere in the
meantime that E Pawn is so strong right
I can even go E3 to at times I can
support it with a knight jumping to F5 I
have a lot of options to improve my
positions as black so this one not
looking good for a Tata I have to say
Irina is showing her might but another
one that I've been looking uh at is the
one between gulrook begin to kill Genova
versus Sophie Mori Suzuki because I have
to say begum is making the Right Moves
In this one taking more and more space
with each and every move and putting a
lot of pressure on Sophie's clock as we
are getting ready to enter that time
travel situation in pretty much all of
the games 9 minutes and 50 seconds and
counting for Sophie and I have to say C4
is coming I'm gaining more and more
space with every move C4 I'm going to
gain more space on this side I will
follow that up with F4 I'm going to gain
more space on the king side as well how
are you going to respond to all of that
pressure I don't have any weaknesses
this spawn on A5 is nicely protected by
the queen on dito I'm ready to jump to
B6 at any time you have to keep the
Knight on D7 you cannot go and search
for your own counter Play Because Knight
to B6 is going to come and if I manage
to get this knight from A4 to C4
increase the pressure on the pawn on D6
well that's going to be problematic for
Black's position I really like what
white is doing in this one in the game
between
Genova and Sophie Maurice Suzuki and
ashrita versus Alice well yes this one
is crazy and by the way guys she took a
part this last move Bishop to A3 oh
the engine is jumping all over the place
it's saying plus five sorry minus 5.4 so
black Alice has a winning move no but
because it's 35. yes Queen H1 is coming
yes how do you defend against it what do
you mean like you cannot do the castling
yeah
we have three Arbiters the convinces
like so you have to go backwards right
right but guess what this night is
coming
I have a Checkmate threat somewhere I
don't see it yet but well first of all
night to F3 is going to win material
Knight to D3 it looks extremely
promising as well okay this is bad guys
this is bad for us two pieces yeah minus
5.4 if Alice finds this move crucial
move C5 Queen to H1 also wins yeah
so controlling right Queen to H1 let's
see King to E2 you want to take that
yeah so we should try it no but if you
take I take on P6 it seems like I'm
getting so close to you there's a
Checkmate threat right so that might be
problematic yeah this is not good she
has to go C5 save the bishop on D6 keep
control around her king and you don't
have enough pieces as White Queen ate
any problems any mating attack while on
the other side your king only one is in
big big danger after Knight jumps to E5
uh yeah deep Waters I have to say for
ashwita in this one if Alice finds C5
it's a C5 is what by the way on the
board on the board I think that's one of
the things where you you have a game
you're on the back foot in fact you're
in great danger but you keep your nerve
you hold it and then when opportunity
comes you're there to find it Queen
takes H5 and C5 by Alice uh really is
turning this game around in her favor do
we have the move after C5 I don't know I
think she played this she made a move
but what would be one she looked to be
one okay that's a good move because it
does defend against Queen H1 check
threats now that the Rook is protected
by the way does it with a gain of tempo
give me me at the bishop but I suspect
there's a really really big problem the
next movie so it might be deep wait a
second there is a beautiful move we
should try to find it that's right yes
sir you found it he found it geometry
guys if you go Rook takes B1 there's a
check that's a piece that what what a
way what a way to defend the vicious
puzzle Rush yeah Ray Robson rugby one D4
before he's a big move big money move
like Maurice likes to say what is it big
money move the money
and you have to defend your position and
then to find the way actually to attack
I mean it's really impressive so far I
mean you don't want to say anything
until the game is finished but so far it
was really good play uh by a clear uh
chess is a young ladies Game 12 years
old look at this and by the way and
let's try to defend okay so what if I
yes what if I take on D4 I know you take
you're giving me something dangerous
checks yeah where's the Checkmate though
what do you do well shall we start yes I
was thinking about that route to G1 oops
Rook to G1 yeah yes
maybe King F7 now
remember to invite everybody to the
party
wow wow that was a beautiful move king
of seven this King went all the way to
d8
to give a Checkmate it's pretty nice
pretty nice wow if she wins this game
like that it's gonna be really really
big victory guest of honor for today wow
and uh By the way when we did the money
uh prizes we forgot to mention there is
a special Bobby Fisher bonus price Bobby
faircher famously won the U.S
Championship with a perfect score
anybody anybody who goes 13.
and oh we'll pick up sixty four thousand
dollars this one small tiny detail yes
going 13-0
even Bobby didn't do that he didn't go
13-0 in as a U.S Championship oh right
well Alice Lee uh we'll keep an eye on
Anna Jennifer well once again that game
still looks very very balanced tatv
well look at this she did uh Arena did
capture on e4 with the gain of tempo
Queen F2 and oh black just has so many
nice moves nicest appears to my eyes to
be nice 5 and E3 again this night on
Eighth A3 is terrible yes even if you
were to bring it to C3 I would prefer
Black's position but on A3 it's simply
offsides big Advantage Arena as well in
this game Sabina Naji they managed to
trade upon
the position is opening up let's see
what happened well both players got in
their respective breaks F5 and F4
and we're up to date with the players
um
I don't know what's going on I'd have to
really take a a more deeper look in this
game First Impressions though are
better white like this Knight is really
awkward like how do we deal with this
Knight
I don't like it I know walking in into a
little danger zone over here and also a
queen of three maybe even asking
questions as well but Knight F6 oh I
don't know it's like
maybe take
ideas of maybe bishop takes and Knight
F4 yes
um looks like well we'll keep an eye on
that what is caught your uh attention in
the open uh Christian I am back in the
open section because this one is uh
exploding the game between Christopher
you and Hans Neiman actually Hans with
only four minutes right now on the clock
so definitely getting close to uh that
time trouble situation this is what we
have on the board A1 Bishop to F7 goes
back Rook to E5 why didn't you play
rookie five
you lost one tempo there's no reason for
that Knight to F6 Knight F E3 and now we
have H4 from Hans a very committal move
because this what allows it uh what
allows white to do is to include his
Queen into the attack with the move
Queen to F2 let's see if he finds this
uh Chris for you that is for example if
you take on G3 Queen takes G3 now
already this king is starting to feel a
little bit of heat because Knight takes
F5 is coming Knight to E4 unfortunately
doesn't work take Knight takes F5 and
the game is over taking advantage of the
pin on the G file you cannot do that if
you uh put in your sneakers as yes
well check this out I have some other
ideas on the other side as well
softening your structure up if you do
take Knight takes C4 taking advantage of
this pin very nice right you did not get
off uh the pin so unfortunately btx A4
is not possible
H4 big moment right now if you do play
Queen to F2 you're going to start
putting a lot of pressure on Black's
position according to the engine black
is still fine in fact black is still
better but with very unnatural moves the
way I see it Knight to H5 it's not a
very natural move no you spend so much
time trying to get that Knight to E4
that's the dream square and finally
you're going to go to the other side you
came from A6 A6 C7 E8 F6 all the way to
the other Rim it doesn't make a lot of
sense right but so you want to take on
F4 of course of course and if you take
then you take on a G3 first you don't
take on H4 because you just simply on H5
because you lose a pawn after uh G takes
H4 so you take on G3 take on G3 Rook
takes H5 and it does seem like you have
some pressure on the H file this Rook is
staying on E5
please take it yes that's what I want as
white I want to include this now light
into the attack via D4 I would love for
you to take on E5 you're probably not
going to do that you're probably just
going to leave it here and once again
what I'm envisioning is some sort of a
Stell me because I'm going to go Knight
to D1 followed by Knight to F2 to defend
against your potential attack and
Invasion over the H file and then what
you're going to do is just wait not take
on E5 not allow this Knight to get to D4
this is just going to be a stalemate in
my opinion nevertheless Queen to F2 by
the way is on the bottom on the board
maybe we can see right now has his
reaction because he's dropping down to
his last four minutes this is a big
moment if he plays Knight H5 and that's
an important move in the position guys
otherwise he might be in trouble by the
way just from hanza's body posture I see
a little bit of suffering going on there
are some nerves there because uh that
move Queen F2 was not on the script yeah
I mean that the queen with the White
Queen much like the Knight on C2 was
supposed to be passive it really looks
like Christopher is the one who seems to
be in time trouble Yes actually 10 moves
yes to go I mean that's a lot though
that's a lot that that 30 second bonus
how important is that with each move you
get the increment uh time thank you
Bobby Fischer for that one really thank
you for those who like to think right
like me yes but will you find the move
Knight H5 is Knight H5 the well you're
saying it's the best movement it's by
far the best move or the alternative
being well
wow okay but logical move and the way
that yeah you don't want to take on G3
let's push the pawn but what's happening
here okay I'm afraid that after you take
Rook H3 going to tour
like what's going on
uh it feels like that move really raised
the ante uh for just a moment here
what's going on after that move
Christian well what if I take on D5
Bishop takes D5 Bishop takes or not how
do we feel Bishop takes actually let's
go Knight takes D5 how do we think about
the calculation after that one Knight
takes D5 well wow there's
just a second what's going on night
takes time I think it's D5 yeah you I
don't think you can take on E5 because
and there's actually a very nice reason
why you cannot Knight to B6 now and the
Queen on F2 after I take on E5 with the
D Pawn is going to protect that Knight
oops that's nice
it looks nice Queen
a78 I think this is the point this is
the point I capture with the tempo that
Knight is being attacked with a chat as
is this a rook on A8 so oh my gosh so
Knight takes D5 so perhaps you have to
take right right I think survive I take
back with the bishop
quickly if you take on E5 I continue
taking on A8
and say how is this position
this is a dream for white first of all
at the moment I'm upon up I recognize
you can play Bishop F4 but this Knight
on C2 is waiting
to play a big role in the game wow wow
wow uh Knight take pardon me Knight
takes D5 looks opportunity it's an
opportunity yes yes absolutely oh my
goodness so Knight takes D5 once again
this is this is the nice move right here
you have to see Knight B6 Christopher
whoa whoa whoa this could really turn
the game around
not G4 okay interesting nice
oh it didn't he missed it he missed it
the second time he plays rookie too
which is yeah
E2 another mistake but like you say it's
just so difficult no it's so difficult
from a human's perspective right because
how are you going to follow it up with
black where is your attack how do you
continue you mean after the move no
after rookie two after the last move
that he would he just played how do you
continue do you open up the age file I
think that was what H3 was all about
right yes to take on G2 but then I take
back let's see with maybe with a knight
maybe I want to go to H Ford
improve the position of my knight clock
the H file well truth be told I always
wanted to drop my knife
and what if I take that exactly uh maybe
opening up a new uh Avenue yeah yeah
this is getting dicey I have to say
because you will at some point take on
E5 indeed I will
but for the moment uh we're pressing on
the H file with the doubled Rooks or the
queen no it's just 94 at 94 right away
even without even even without it okay
let's have a look what 88 was placed he
played rookie did let's not forget also
that Hans has only like couple of
minutes left so rookie two is also like
okay I give you the move please think
about it maybe for three minutes wow
yeah please by the way the move Rook d8
that's a little confounding as well I
mean I understand that you want to open
up the H file so why did we put the Rook
on D I think he's trying to undirect
indirectly protect D5 no like if you
take on D5 sometimes Bishop B5 so if we
go for that old line before obviously
The Rook is now vacated uh the action
then perhaps I can start with Bishop
takes D4 now Bishop takes D4 now
wow
oh tricky very it's not as that's
important because if you had just
allowed me that one moment to play D
takes E4
get my well that that that does it so
unfortunately the opportunities take on
D5 has passed and now I have to come up
with something clever what's clever
Queen E1
like maybe on a good day I can offer a
trade of Rooks
I'm I'm uh I'm confused I admit and then
you guys like this position is really
complicated and it's really hard for
Hans to play with couple of minutes on
his clock by the way but the time is
ticking down yes but it's white to play
now Christopher still has 32 minutes but
he can think for another 20.
very nice we have to keep an eye on this
game absolutely Jeffrey versus darrish
again that was that whole clogged
position with the A5 uh I think for me
this is unique I'm used to an alakain
gun yes for a single player not for both
yes it's football
I've been around but I must admit this
is this is a unique uh you have it in
your book even yesterday I do I do but
well again for one player for one player
Sam Shanklin versus Ray Robson also a
bit of a standoff guys we have to go to
the Alice League game yes let's go let's
run that one and maybe we can see the
camera oh
pretty much
uh Alice's feeling really really good
here where's this King going well that's
a good question let's let let's now
before with the idea that night cannot
protect uh both yes yes and if you take
Queen B1 beautiful oh that's a geometry
nice there's so much geometry in this
position
okay and if I do it on the E3 Square she
went to D3 but if you go to uh E3 now
finally I include my last piece into the
attack I take on D4 you take back yes
and then 90 series oh coffee shop before
he's on the board guys the issue before
Alice Alice what the game wow wow that
is really nice especially even getting a
96 yeah that that one is actually easier
yes yes the night coming to E6 that that
that's
but this one king D3 Bishop E4 can I
keep running
I don't know where I'm heading to just
heading for the hills okay I'll just
take it it's time to take a look take
the material
I mean I'm two pieces up and you're
nowhere close to delivering any checks
actually yes that that uh you're making
a good point
by the way your king is also on Seafood
you're two pieces up my King's on C4 and
I don't even have a threat uh yeah okay
I think that I think we'll we're going
to see a handshake this is the game you
want to play in U.S Championship I mean
when you play for the first time and you
were 12 for a minute you can remember
this day for a long time it's a good way
to start a campaign that's for sure
by the way I always like it to call uh
tournaments that feature Alice Lee
because as a very young lady she started
her own TV show oh yes on the internet
called Alice's Alice's Alice Pond Palace
she had Alice chess Palace and very very
popular uh amongst kids uh 12 years
young wow that's really cool very very
if I was kid at this period of time so
many opportunities now yes you can start
your Twitch Channel you can start your
YouTube channel I'm jealous of all of
these opportunities that are existing in
the world of Chess today and in the game
of begum and uh Sophie uh by the way
guys I just want to pinpoint the fact
that ashwita is a third rated player in
this event right she becomes 2400 so
Victory against the Third Rate player in
the event with the black pieces in this
fashion that's boost of confidence
absolutely that's making a statement to
everybody in the competition I just
wanted to say that that begum act on
here we have that standings coming in
Arena the highest rated player 2432 but
as you were saying the shritha third
sure 2365. where is it
let's see if we can go back producers to
that where is Alice Lee all the way down
there looks like a nice place she's on
on the oh yes on the 10th Place yes if I
remember
22.63 Master that's such a big
difference still in Raging only 100
points so let's say in this age it's not
that important with K40 I mean when you
can get that in master class what what
age were you when you broke the master
class for me that was a a huge barrier
that 2200. well I actually I started
with this you know the first event I
ever played I was 14. and immediately I
got the rating 2200. producer
you were immediately it was different
times you know at that time yes sir you
remember like you go to International
Event and you immediately get the rate
okay somehow this kind of thing like the
Assumption was you you were so good 1800
for example you are from the beginning
let's say and then you play the
tournament I played it well the first
event I think I scored like five and a
half out of nine it was in Hungary and
immediately I got 224 testing and I
never went too far away from it
my goodness first rating I think my
first rating and I was massively
overrated in 1100
[Laughter]
you know it's just like I was we were
playing in Ukraine let's say and then
suddenly in some youth events and this
was not my first open tournament I ever
played so this is what happened it
sounds to me like you were born a master
get out of here this is terrible I mean
how about you Christian when you broke
that for me the expert to master was
just it was a bridge too far I just wow
it was so hard when did you become a
master I think I went from 1800 uh in
one tournament that's because the K was
40.
um I think all the way to like close to
2200 yes uh in and I think at that point
the lists were coming out every three
months not every month so I had a lot of
time to pick up the pace and gain those
300 rating points or something along
those lines and with that I also got
defeated Master title so for me that was
a big and I think that was a big
breakthrough and this one by the way is
over between Sam Shanklin and Ray Robson
and we were talking about the stalemate
in that position the pawn on H3 is
beautiful but there is no way unless
white cooperates with you and opens up
the default to make any progress great
and by the way just uh going back to the
reach so how old were you again uh
Christian just how old were you I want
to say I was around 12 which is Alice's
Alice's age that's what I mean that's
competition
but she's been 22.50 since she was 10 or
something like those lines right yeah I
mean this is incredible yeah a shritha
versus Alice we did see after Bishop E4
Knight takes E4 Queen takes B1 check
these were the moves that we were
discussing our road to chess Mastery
born and I wanted to ask uh well yeah
that's that that one is over Queen E1
why not taking on D4 and then 96 but
take on D4 you take on D4 is as simple
same variation which Christians told us
three I go Queen D3 that finishes the
game I'm picking up all of your pieces
oh gosh that's terrible yep that makes
sense and if you take on D4 96 I'm
picking up the Rook or even yeah even
Bishop
okay too many uh wonderful and how many
how much time does she have because she
does seem a little bit nervous yeah no I
don't see the tank right now
oh yeah you know she took on D4 I mean
captured why not right we start the
seconds normal you can make it
six minutes okay that's plenty of time
for Alice she knows she has this one in
the back absolutely guys a lot of things
are happening please the Christ for you
versus Hans Newman so maybe we can jump
to that one let's do it lots of things
have happened again uh three draws in
the open section and we're jumping to
the game between Christopher you and
Hans Neiman Hans finally by the way I
mean he couldn't resist he resisted for
a long while I think G3 G4 was more or
less the siren Call that said okay in
this position F5 is crumbling I don't
want to see uh a double capture on F5 I
have to take the Rook Christopher
recaptured Pawn is on G2 there is this
very nasty threat of Rook H1 but doesn't
Rook takes G2 let's take the opportunity
right let's take it how do we assess
this position well now
I would say three result game my first
instinct is like wait a minute if I get
my knight to D4 like if it was my turn
and obviously taking on F5 is a huge
threat at the moment so I have to do
something fast but if if I already had
my knight on D4 I would think White's
winning let's go Rook H3 Rook H3 okay H3
Rook h8 tried to meet you and attack the
bishop at the same time uh makes a lot
of sense of course but maybe you can
take on a five no immediately before I
mean so it started to see some of us but
I'm not sure maybe maybe maybe yeah
maybe it's too much yes I don't know
let's see we see him hovering over the
rook and that's your favorite thing to
do 95 yes
I guess is oops and we do have Rook
takes G2 on the board will we again Rook
H3 yes he's done it he played it so nine
to five is really tempting especially
when your opponent has like couple one
minute maybe at the moment okay so with
this check by the way where is the king
going yeah
he's six and quickly too it was bing
bang
what is this move I think oh no I feel
it really be a good move no Knight F5
was definitely something was there I
don't know what but I don't think so
guys what if I just simply take with the
bishop yeah and protect the five yes
this is what you want I want to protect
this phone please okay but for sure his
idea is that he's got a bishop G4 so
Bishop takes F5 uh he's got Knight takes
F5 in mind with Bishop G4 to follow in
case you go down this yeah
uh but it strikes me that well I I have
a lot of options here maybe Rook of
three no Rook just six of them yes well
no just to check
[Music]
um where am I moving my king not sure
yes no it still looks so dangerous
though right okay by the way sorry
um anything to be said for Queen takes
E6 Pawn takes F5 I don't take on F5 I
think I'm going Knight D4 first I see a
queen I'm gonna uh I was about to play
Queen to B6 uh in some cases but Knight
to D maybe Knight takes F5 check oh
that's nice
okay okay okay that was uh all right
before good morning St Louis uh
he's taken with the bishop yes yes so
once more we take on F5 and we're hoping
for a bishop G4
uh shot
the problem is after Bishop takes F5 do
you have Bishop to G4
this is what we discussed this what do
you mean
you want to take first and then but now
isn't Rook h8 a problem
ah
after Bishop G4 Rook h8
wow great fine Christian
well thank you
[Laughter]
maybe now immediately look at shape
no
Bishop
five yes but he's burned his Bridges has
white white uh oh pardon me I he could
play Knight D4 94 is actually
a fairly decent move I defend the bishop
and I'm ready to pick up this one with a
check
one thing that right now Christopher you
has to be aware of is the fact that
we're three moves away from making the
time control right and if he does that
and Hans gets enough time to think about
the position I have filling this one
might be in the back for Hans so
Christopher has to find something and he
has to find it quick do not allow Hans
to safely get to the second time control
exactly
so and it's not easy it's easier said
than done because the position actually
objectively is winning for Hans right
now exactly but uh 94 uh what is the
main
just get out of Dodge seven yeah
just getting out and actually that King
is extremely safe on it on F7 right now
it definitely feels that way to me as
well the problem of course is uh this
Knight on e4 is just so strong but I
can't get rid of it by playing Bishop
takes and if I take on F5 like something
like this I'm just not getting
sufficient compensation anymore so
perhaps a more practical approach is to
take on F5 and then go Knight to D4 and
try to break with F5 okay fair
interesting yes and then 90 for now okay
no you cannot do that it works it works
nice work that's the family Fork Knight
to D4 all right out taking or he did
take an effort he took on F5 he did take
on F5 and we do have this position so 94
so
well 39 guys this is move 39. so extreme
Precision required by Hans for the next
couple of moves to maintain his
advantage
let's see if he finds it Queen to F6 is
a big one yes it's like and after F5
King h8 no h a yeah I love that I was
about to suggest that Knight G5 but then
Rook takes G5 and order to play 96.
check
check nice check but uh Rook takes uh
it's her sorry so uh you don't do that
but King h8
stepping out of Dodge Rook takes Rook G8
perhaps
uh is one way
um yeah yeah nice wow the attack
actually finishes after King h8 it's
it's just by the way guys one minute for
Hans two more moves to make
will you find the right more or less the
only move or what or queen D7 you can
also think of not really yes because 27
is lost after Bishop to G4
so yeah you have to go on F6 yes Queen
D7 Bishop G4 Knight E6 never in mind
never mind this Rook uh definitely so
Queen F6 is actually boss yes
a big moment guys yes exactly big moment
right now will he find queen of yes he
finds it
wow a little bit nervous a little
uncertainty
he held the queen for just he made it
with seven 17 seconds on the clock yes
so right now he has 47 seconds for one
move one more move for Hans
well Christopher had has to speed things
up he has to play F5 F5 with the ideas
of 96 Jack Bishop takes and the more
obvious Rook take G6 is met by this
incredibly counter-intuitive move but
you just step away from the night but he
has to find it guys you step away from
the night you step away from the rook
and you say do your worst and there's
not a lot of worse to be done
yeah that's nice you can get shade
really hard to find I love that move oh
yes yes really visually once you see it
for books right yeah once you visually
see it you go oh that's so nice you're
stepping away from all of White's
threats and after a move like Rook takes
G6 you're you're introducing the idea
that it's White's King actually I'm far
more vulnerable than black skin nice
nice nice
wow
um as we're getting lost in this game
and I I'm not going to move away from it
I'm just going to take a look on my
analysis board we'll keep the light
board I'm just going to take a quick
look at fobby's position love linear's
position I think he's got he's got a big
Advantage going on over there between
Jeffrey and uh darush things have been
stabilized for quite some time Sam
sevion versus elshon
looks like Sam has a huge Advantage
maybe even a a checkmating Advantage
with G5 and Rook G8 so let me just come
back to the game though
what does he though does he does he know
can I go G5 Rook desaf2
can you go G5 are you catching that pawn
oh five I noticed it but oh oh oh uh
What uh
for the bishop to come back in time
that's funny so maybe I have to play F4
and G5 so you can't trade Rooks yes
something of that nature that's kind of
funny
um and again this is the game between
Christopher
yes it's 47 seconds on his clock because
we're expecting the move F5 and Hans
plays King h8 he'll have a winning
position
uh lots of ways still for Hans to go
wrong though uh right Christian
absolutely but he has uh Chris for you
that is to play the move F5 actually
like what computer says after movie five
any other movies except you can get
shared leads us but they're not as
conclusive yeah but I mean like so you
lose a lot of your advantage if you
don't play King agent but still you can
hold it yes because it feels it but
unclear if you're still winning okay if
you don't find King to h8 Rook to G8 is
a move after that but F5 it does seem
like at least from a practical
perspective has to be played yeah
by the way now that you mention it after
F5 Rook G8 also looks like a very
tricky but good idea because Rook takes
G6
be the same and Knight E6 check King
goes back is still the same it does so
then I can probably just take on e4 and
then take only four back with the queen
and just play for a compensation in that
fashion I see okay that makes makes
sense and if I played King h8 right away
I release my queen
into the attack
yeah not so it's a really difficult
moment and everyone was in time travel
right yes sir I mean it's like a very
very tense moment like your opponent is
thinking and you know that you have only
40 seconds left right so you're under
huge pressure at this at this time yeah
and it felt like a little bit of a
roller coaster game there where
Christopher definitely had his
opportunity to play the move Knight
takes D5
uh and rookie five right away so let's
say it's like he lost a little bit of
time during that game yeah he rushed
some decisions did Christopher
um and again I feel like uh make your
move
so he could see the rest of the games F5
what else is there beside F5 by the way
maybe just take only four and try to
play it like that but that doesn't feel
right because that invites Rook to h8
yes
and also this type of movement which is
to see I know he takes now this is
like you also give your opponent a
chance to play the simplest move in the
position right you don't really cause
any problem when you have so much less
time left the other problem is maybe
bishop takes E4 Rook E8 and I'm missing
anything no you're not that's right just
looks like I could recapture with the
rug and that's a dream come true if if
he finds it the game is pretty much over
rookie eight rookie 8 is a big one
okay 30 seconds 20 seconds 28 and the
engine is giving Hans a uh tremendous
Advantage rookie Ace is on the board
guys yeah
he spent 30 seconds but he made this
move
okay yeah Christopher is not surviving
this one yeah that looks like uh game
over let me just uh switch to the ladies
any time trouble issues
oh well Alice just won her Alice is just
one yes expectedly she won this game yes
beautiful beautiful great game oh boy
the very end position it looks like
she's up a box load of material uh takes
on D4 this is where we left it we saw
this move Knight E6 we thought that was
curtains 96 Bishop F4 and oh oh my gosh
oh
she took all the pieces
of of
Jack and it's a very practical decision
put your faith in absolute pins not just
pins but pins where you know the king is
involved these absolute pins Alice up a
few extra pieces ashwitha through in the
towel we have our first decisive game
from the 2022 US championships a lot of
time travel situations guys and one of
them in particular that game between
back him and Sophie Morris Suzuki Sophie
with only one minute left on her clock
right now and 15 moves to go
but I think that this actually is a
position Sophie found this move D5 and
this was a great shot a a great move
because now in the current position F4
F5 for white is no longer on tap Knight
takes D5 why isn't this position just
better for black well you have to find
something to do right now because it
does feel like with both Rooks on the
Central files there's something hanging
in the air right some Bishop H6 move for
example well that might be a problem
right okay yes
well where do I the problem is I don't
know where I'm supposed to put this
Bishops
probably Bishop H4 because if you go to
D6 I go Bishop H6 still
if I go Bishop to F Barney
Bishop H6 what 15 seconds left guys will
she find Bish page four
F6 Bishop I have six
okay so that invites an endgame how good
is this color
I would assume it's good for what for
white because the problem is the bishop
on H6 is again one of these monstrous
Bishops that always keeps the king
um in these back rank check mating
patterns I would assume that this is but
what if I keep the Queens on the board
and take advantage of the fact that
there are still those cannons DNE file
looking at your queen so Queen F4 Queen
F4 sure or queen B4 both of them seem to
be very yeah so you're you're thinking
try to exploit the possibility of a
double discover check
sorry Bishop to B6 I feel like it's
awesome
because then you lose a pawn at least no
I mean
as you become an experienced Master uh
taking advantage of your opponent's time
Troubles by keeping the position complex
Queen F4 is on the board very important
skill uh to maintain the pressure yeah
to maintain the pressure exactly Queen
f4 on the board and now I think that
clarifies matters a lot what if we take
on y5 Queen takes A5
15 seconds four and Counting Sophie
Queen takes eight five Knight takes F6
and queen takes F6 ideas of Bishop D4
he's got about six like five seconds oh
Bishop H4 in the nick of time but can
you go G5 exactly that was the move I
was afraid of initially when the queen
was on D4 is that Bishop not trapped on
H1 yes
as a threat oh that's a nice one not
only nice not only Queen H4 oh G5 I
think it's over guys yeah 96. I can see
Anastasia that you're warming to the
position
you're seeing yeah he's these very nice
and G5 by the way that just that that
move is so
um
yeah like visual like you just you want
to play this move and cut the connection
between the queen and the bishop so you
can pick up the bishop for free and as
you're saying Knight F6 discovered
attack
and it's well we know the time is a big
factor for Sophie how is it for begum
um I'm sure
I mean like
15 minutes out then I'm sure she'll find
G5 and probably you were mentioning
Bishop B6 there might be other even no
Bishop B6 but G5
right I mean probably the best thing
black can do after G5 is to go into the
end game after Bishop takes G5 and be a
piece down okay that shows a lot not
survival time right yeah it's not what
you want to do and also the exact same
thing you mentioned Anastasia Knight F6
is also a threat she played it G5 yes G5
does that is that one minute
one minute 42 yes one one I'm sorry I
thought that's 15 but it's actually 1.
yeah
thank you
it takes high five
okay well
that invites a lot of things including
just picking up your piece well Knight
E7 check and Knight takes G6 nice as
well yes you you you get to pick up the
bishop on H4 with checks
I have to take with the H Pawn do I even
want to do that I think I want to keep
the Knight on the board it's such a nice
night
so I would take on H4 just give me the
piece take first ask questions later
precisely precisely nice
uh by no uh that's asking too much I I
even started considering 97 check King
h8 and something like Bishop here so
that I could play Bishop takes but of
course I've overlooked Queen takes G5 so
and the problem is much like a good
student she took your advice
and rookie eight on the board
and I think she did you see how shakily
she made ate no I think perhaps she
wanted to go to Da but realized that
Bishop to B6
there is a potential right
uh the these time Troubles by the way
very very much
I started to see some ghosts like some
checkmates here there no I love this
yeah you've been doing your tactics yeah
you've got uh I'm on Checkmate and also
very nice is that it continues the
background Checkmate and I have to go
Queen d8 which is very ugly and then
you've got
five also looks beautiful exactly right
you wanted to escape now she's looking
at that three seconds uh what I want yes
uh what I wanted to say is you know time
trouble it's the strangest thing in
chess sometimes it just causes you like
these brain freezes yes
people make unbel myself included make
unbelievable errors that are
unrecognizable and it's almost a kind of
a nerves you get so nervous with less
time on your clock Bishop D2
if she makes the time control and how
many moves does she have there's plenty
of moves 11 moves still to go 11. it's
move 29. wow wow it's already 29 made
their way to this moment but I think
it's going to be over very very soon
like like
B5 defends excuse me can I go Knight no
Knight C7 doesn't work
but maybe something like well let's try
it once more Rook takes and Rook to E1
and then we've got these
it almost feels like one of those
array uh you know giving up your queen
queen
[Music]
deflection we call this no this trick
yes all right I mean when you try to
actually yeah
she decided to go for something simple
would you have a piece up you don't need
to be too creative at this moment like
okay you exchange one more piece time to
play very practically exactly I'm
thinking rookie one and he won his own
and then like 97 maybe take on G6 Queen
and four at the low something like that
perfect
100 all the way on that one Anastasia
just simplify uh we've been doing it for
1400 years went ahead trade everything
down and uh don't be creative yeah win
with your extra piece it works very very
well stick to the basics Rook 31 then
going to D4 Central your pieces Bishop
to C3 is coming as well yes before
Bishop C3 love it
and at some point there's going to be
some tactics ideas or Knight to E7
actually just on that note I mean let's
just make a move right Queen d8 uh
Bishop C3
of course because of the background mate
we can't take on C3 because the Knight
end we just make a move and suddenly
thump right oops that's interesting is I
don't think it works
though no I just taken Queenie Queen H6
King h8 back
thump is not winning yep that's two but
okay so we have an extra piece we can do
whatever we want so then we do it the
other way oh this is beautiful like you
cannot take on D4 now
and if you go Queen takes G5 that's the
only problem oh that's nice
I have to get it in uh again
so Queen D7 is on the board Queen to D4
just centralizing seems to be finishing
the job
is also about to win his game yes uh
Queen D7 on the board
yes
exactly was not the sixth idea yes
queen queen to D4 just seems to be
decisive
I like the deflection Queen G4 move yes
oh where is she going with that night
Knight to E7 okay E7 check well no
choice here King h8 quickly played very
practical by so by Sophie okay now you
can indeed
take control remember like I said like
since everything you know use the fact
that you have now your plan before yes I
love it we see it up nice
Queen D4 and there's no Chucks that's
the nice thing about wise position right
the king is remarkably safe yeah
yeah even though the Pawn's on G5 yes
rather open uh King shield Queen gb4
followed by Bishop to C3 seems to be
doing the job
wow going before great I like it she's
playing very very well for this time uh
trouble and again the nervousness it's
inescapable I think everybody even
Anatoly karpov the great Anatoly karpoff
and when he would get into time trouble
also
it still feels different when you play
Blitz game right and you have no time
and when you play classical game and
then suddenly you're in time travel I
don't know why but it's somehow
different I have 30 seconds in a
classical game and I'm nervous as I'll
get out I have 10 seconds in a Blitz
game and I'm thinking I have plenty of
time
to finish the Instagram
and again I think the players are going
to make the time travel I'll do it I'll
just say that white is Comfortably
winning what other games are decisive oh
Bishop's history here yes yes Bishop C3
Sims that will be a visual rookie seven
is also if Queen and Rook E8
7 okay I agree with you there are two
options the bishop C3 but they left it
for yeah
Queen takes C3 Rook takes C3 Queen C3 so
we're about to see Bishop C3 but I did
want to ask you Christian uh because as
we're getting into this time trouble
phase did Hans put the Finishing Touch
hasn't finished the game yet but he's
definitely winning yes definitely
winning definitely winning right now
Chris Sam Savion versus elshon that one
is still going still going still very
complex he played a move F4 he did not
miss Rook takes after in that one oh
Queen to f8 there is a Checkmate in two
moves let's see if we're getting into
your position yes sir let's zero create
or queen G7
which one so you have to go for Queen G7
actually she goes for rookie I will be
very upset at her
um
I will be like
look you have to get the Checkmate in
two right checks yes that's the visual
yeah yes of course I know my students
very good what a tough trainer I know
both ways are winning come on what's the
problem but uh yes it looks like pizza
night
pizza for everybody bravo bravo as we
have uh two uh decisive uh games in the
ladies in the open we have three draws
and let's see what else is going on Anna
zatonski Jennifer
whoa
Jennifer won a pawn what
am I looking at this right
Jennifer just upon it I mean it was four
verses actually you're right and we we
don't have uh minor pieces this is just
winning fruit
winning for black yeah wow wow what did
she do she has overlooked something
maybe okay so the Knight went to C6 and
the pawn was more vulnerable there
oh my goodness
oh my goodness
and and here we are the ending
maybe she hopes to still keep it but
very hard I'm not quite sure about King
D7 I think just King B7 and you kind of
nurse made your Pawn up the board
and after check King D7 okay one king D6
okay what he's doing and uh Christian
let's jump over to you we have guest in
studio we are indeed with Alice Lee
Alice a tremendous victory for you to
start off your first USS Championship
with the black pieces against the third
highest rated player in the event how
does that feel well I still haven't
really registered it yet because like
this game was like really chaotic I
wasn't even sure about the result near
the very end but obviously this is a
great result for me to begin the
tournament with and I definitely wasn't
expecting this because you know she is
like very strong and I'm black anywhere
under tremendous pressure early on she
played this idea wrote the G1 G4 G5 she
was really coming at you pushing the
pawns and trying to destroy your Castle
how did you strategize your defense at
this point yeah I mean I wasn't really
sure about the opening because I think a
move once usually plays like E4 or more
recently Knight of three
um she started with C4 so I was sort of
surprised for move one and then usually
in these like C4 C6 sort of structures I
think I
um usually she plays like D4 and
transposes into a Marin but after Rook
G1 I didn't really know what to do so I
just sort of played safe but it was a
bit passive with like a rookie eight and
Knight f8 Knight D7
uh and I think my play was a little bit
too slow but uh here it's not too bad
um I think I wanted to like Bishop B7
and then possibly like E5 that was my
plan
um but then she started going down an
attack so she played this both G uh G6
after Bishop to D3 this was the moment
did you see this move Bishop takes H7
did you consider it
um
no
wow so Knight takes H7 and now the key
is that she has to open up this diagonal
as well so she needs to sacrifice
another piece it actually makes sense
because then she wants to play G6 and
then the bishop and B2 and their country
one are very strong exactly yes and it
does seem like this one might be winning
for her but she did not spot that uh she
played the move G6 did she play this
move fast uh I don't exactly remember uh
I don't think she spent that much time
on it uh oh she spent eight minutes uh
actually difference here yeah I thought
that like this was good because after F
takes G6 if she does H takes G6 I should
be able to do H6 and close the position
um I thought this should be fine for me
since like I don't see how she can
really attack me it doesn't seem like
there's a way to break and if she does
open up the B2 Bishop you can close it
with E5 that was my plan I think uh but
she played Knight G5 which I definitely
wasn't expecting so here uh at first I
saw like H6 should just be good for me
um but then I saw that she had this
Knight F7 idea or also Bishop takes G6
um and if Knight takes G6 Knight F7 I
think and then that would be pretty
annoying that's waiting for her yeah so
um so I was planning to do H takes G5 I
think in the game I did B Tech V4 I took
on C4 first yeah yeah how did you came
up to that conclusion that you have to
eliminate donate these two parts uh well
later on I wasn't really sure whether it
was good because my Keen was more open
but here I thought that like maybe at
some point I might play some 95 ideas so
um not right now although uh it does
seem that it's okay but I saw H6 I think
H6 were very well calculated and this
was more or less forced at this point so
actually
um after Bishop takes G6 check earlier
uh I was considering uh move 18 uh King
G8 but she can take on E8 and then I
thought like maybe I could do 95 but
after Castle's Queen side Queen takes E8
and then F4
um it looks like she has some of those
same bishop and B2 work and G1 found in
G7 idea seems to be winning for her yeah
no you made the right decision you went
towards the center with King E7 and
actually this seems to have been the
decisive mistake after Queen to A4
already things are starting to look good
for you because your queen is getting
close to Hurricane and this was the big
one yeah Bishop 283 yeah and now it
seems like her Queen is sort of
completely out of play on 85 I mean
especially since my king is on E8 I
think that's better place than on C8
where there might be some I don't know a
night A4 ideas
um so after C5 then now I have like many
ideas and you found this move d4 to
defend the bishop B7 indirectly yeah
yeah because the Rook takes B7 Queen H1
uh Alice I have to say after this you
play the best moves uh according to the
engines as well just brilliant play by
you defended nicely how does it feel to
win this one and what does that mean for
your chances to potentially become U.S
women's champion
um well of course it's great to be able
to win this one and just get it over
with like black pieces against such a
top seed
um as for winning the championship I
don't really think I can think about
that right now especially since there's
like 12 more games to go and I think
tomorrow will be white against Beacon
and that would be a very tough game take
it one day at a time congratulations
Alice we'll see you tomorrow thank you
our congratulations to you as well Alice
it always feels like great when you're a
debut and you make a win but let's take
a look at our results thus far just two
games yes
lost against Dallas and then we have
also
begum who won against Sofia yes that was
really really nice game but a lot of
topsy-turvy results here going on Fabi
he was in a terrible I want to say Dire
Straits against Lanier they are now in a
dead drawn Bishops of opposite color
ending that game will end in a draw
we'll likely see four draws in the open
section and that was just a terrible
tournament Lanier is going to look at
this game and say what am I doing that
was very very peculiar King G8 by the
way an invitation to making a three move
repetition and we'll jump back to
Christian yes
thank you Yasser beg him first of all
congratulations a good start for your uh
2022 campaign how does this Victory feel
very important because first days are
kind of like
slow and it's a good win Good Start how
did you strategize let's say the opening
phase you started off with E4 C5 and it
did feel like after Bishop to D7 you
started thinking a little bit yeah
actually I didn't expect this x move at
all just for one second we're going to
interrupt you because Hans has won his
game against Christopher you and starts
his 2022 campaign with a crucial Victory
yes he does this he's the only one
that's hard to win the open back to you
Christian
again back to the position oh yeah I
didn't expect a D6 at all she never
played that that's why I was like okay
let's be a little bit creative because
main move is D4 which I play and I have
a lot of games there I was like
probably she's ready and I just started
to create I I knew some ideas but I'm
not sure if I did
uh
if I did the Right Moves A4 I just saw
at some point like A4 exists so
basically that's why not try why not try
it right
Knight to C6 Castle Knight to F6 where
did you feel comfortable with your
position E6 D4 I was surprised she
played Bishop G4 move I thought this
position should be slightly better for
me maybe she shouldn't be like spending
that's why after Bishop G4 I thought
maybe she's gonna take on F3 and try
something I I wasn't really sure
yeah just after I played G4 Bishop G2
Knight C3 like I felt like I was better
like slightly better not not much
and then we got to this position and he
played this uh nice prophylactic move
Queen to D2 which the panel was praising
um how did you feel about your chances
at this point uh at this point I thought
okay I don't have much but it was like a
playable position I just wanted to play
it and I was just waiting for her to to
shuffle her pieces more so I can
understand the position better and I
think whatever she did is not that great
but my reaction wasn't a very precise in
my opinion she played like Knight B6
here right
and she also started burning a lot of
time yeah and I was thinking a lot too
but it's understandable first day you
you want to like really go into the game
even though she was spending more time
because after D6 probably she didn't
expect Bishop B5 and it's it's a kind of
like new position for her too that's why
and then probably she was a little bit
afraid to like uh to do something very
very bad let's say that's why she was
just spending she was a little bit
afraid to play the position I guess
it was more familiar for me because I'm
an E4 player so it just didn't matter
and you also have more space it just
feels like it flows easier for you yeah
I think maybe A5 is not that great maybe
I just had to play Rook D1 immediately
seems like get moved to my eyes into the
engine size as well so that's good a 597
Knight A4 seems uh like you're building
up I was thinking maybe she was trying
to play Knight C5 but after D5
I thought that was already but still
it's a difficult position for black yeah
and she had to make a decision because
she only had seven minutes at this point
that's sure rotative one
so I think this was the critical moment
the next critical moment and she made
her move with something along the lines
I missed Bishop H4 and when we got this
position like before uh we got this
position before I took on D5 yeah before
I took on D5 I I just realized I missed
uh Bishop H4 because my idea was just to
take with the bishop and after 95 I
thought I was winning and that's why I
was a little bit angry at myself that I
missed Bishop H4 but I was like okay if
she finds it then Queen a four and night
before is is a threat that's why it just
decided to go it's not easy it's not
easy especially with a few seconds on
the Block we we both at this point had
like only a minute so I was like okay if
she finds it it's fine we'll just keep
playing it and it doesn't seem like the
only way out might be something like
Rook to E2 okay this is
yeah this is not easy to find
um and if you don't find Rook to yes
that's why she didn't play Bishop H4 she
also thought after quitting F4 the night
before his coming I I to be honest I
thought that that's why that's the
reason why she didn't play but after
Bishop F6 Queen F4 suddenly she's just
losing yeah like there's no way
already you picked up the piece and
after that you finished in a nice
Fashion After Queen to uh f8 Queen takes
G7 and I was saying that we're going to
have a big discussion if you play Rook
to E8 instead of Queen takes G7 I was
very happy that she gave me the a chance
to check my enter usually just people
resign earlier so it's nice to start
with a Checkmate absolutely
congratulations backing and we'll see
you in the next few rounds thank you now
congratulations to you as well a very
nice finish indeed and again we're
seeing these like topsy-turvy results
coming in uh as Fabi and Lanier did make
a draw we think that Fabio is really
fortunate to dodge a bullet in this game
in the game between Jeffrey and uh
darush
um Jeffrey I mean after a heavy heavy
heavy maneuvering has finally won the
pawn on e4 and appears to be in the
driver's seat and also in the ladies big
turnaround in the game between tatsef
and Arena as a tatv is now in the
driver's seat and she was in big trouble
Anastasia as we saw uh it was quite some
time ago but just to catch up on some
results Sabina versus Naj that game
ended in a draw Talia versus Rue Yang
also wrong so results and back to
Christian with a guest thank you Yasser
we are with Hans Neiman after an
incredible Victory with the black pieces
against the fellow Junior Christopher
you Hans first of all let's address the
elephant in the room you've been under a
lot of pressure tell us a bit about that
well um I think that this game is a is a
message to everyone and uh you know this
entire thing started with me saying
chess speaks for itself and uh I think
this game spoke for itself and showed
the chess part of that I am and it also
showed that um I'm not going to back
down and I'm going to play my best chess
here regardless of the pressure that I'm
under and that's all I have to say about
this game and
you know
chess speaks for itself you know that's
all I can say let's discuss the game a
little bit that's it but uh you know you
can leave it to interpretation but thank
you that is that's it all you want to
say yes because it was such a beautiful
game I don't even need to describe it
thank you
right that's it
okay
I actually had one question if we're
still in studio I guess not no because
disappeared but I wanted to ask about
the Knight takes D5 moment I I don't
think he wanted to speak I answer uh the
Knight takes D5 he came into the studio
and he said we're not going to analyze
the game I just want to say something
and that was it okay it was a message
for the world and he spoke with his
moves today he spoke with his moves
today we felt that Christopher and I
have the position in front of my uh on
my analysis board and the question that
I I had for Chris Christopher for Hans
pardon me was right here when the move
rookie 2 was played we thought that
Christopher could really put the
pressure on Hans with the move Knight
takes D5 and I wanted to ask about that
that's right now we can only ask
Christians no
laughs
all right we do have a special about
last night's opening ceremonies which
was held here in St Louis at the St
Louis aquarium which was a wonderful
location by the way and we had many many
many guests all showing up for the
induction and uh well it was a wonderful
it was a wonderful opening ceremony it
was also wonderful place to visit of
course it's important to place for Saint
Louis aquarium right we could do those
were the plaques of the new inductees
you see Rochelle and Jennifer two close
friends there
is
[Music]
getting ready for their speeches
our dear friend Jim and I were roommates
back in the late 70s in Hollywood
California and the legendary Eugenia
Tori gave a very heartfelt speech
thanking everybody
for his induction
and also we had the drawing the floats
and it was conducted with really nice
toys yeah gutters and sharks and sharks
yeah so you can imagine that in open
section they picked up sharks why did
the ladies get the
otters
in the open section the Sharks yeah I'll
try to guess what
U.S championship
yes we're awesome as well and for Ray
Ray actually is a super veteran he's
played maybe half his life in these U.S
championships and I'm not joking he has
played so many of them and uh
just before we go on a break yes we have
only two games left right same seven I'm
still playing with elshon and Jeff
frixon is fighting with uh sweet sweet
exactly uh one win is Hans Neiman will
lead the tournament after round one
unless Jeffrey can catch him and we'll
see you on the other side of the break
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States
the St Louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant Central West End has
established itself as a premier Global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and Scholastic Center of
St Louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays hosts to
all major tournaments including the U.S
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand Masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of Chess to
Children throughout the St Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing Scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 Schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the World Chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the U.S and World Chess Halls
of Fame Cutting Edge exhibitions feature
rare historic chess artifacts paired
with world-class art Innovative
programming explores the intersection of
Chess art and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries the World
Chess Hall of Fame is nothing you expect
and everything you love three different
Galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity Behind The Game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the St Louis chess campus visit
stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone to our studio and
we have some results and some games are
still in the progress uh same Savion and
El Sean are still playing Jeffrey and
Darius are still also playing during the
game and we have all draws except one
game yes three times one on the black
side against Christopher you a nice
victory at least Hans was very proud of
it and in the ladies uh what what about
the results in the ladies Anastasia
let's check the ladies same here we have
two games we have two games left right
out of the seven I know sorry for
deadliest like we have three results
already wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute I think we have a number of
draws Italia also made a draw I think
it's really Yang but you're right they
had three decisive games three decisive
games you have and still we have two
very big games uh going on uh Anna
zatonski versus Jennifer Yu in this Rook
ending that we are about to see Jennifer
has been nursing an extra Pawn for quite
some time I thought it was a very easy
win Jennifer is actually making life
very difficult for herself she's moved
her King all the way up to the B3 Square
what she should have done is simply
dropped the king back to the corner
here now she's threatening to make slow
but steady progress with Asics and King
A7 and nurse upon up the board after he
moved for example like Rook A1 you can
go Rook C6 play A6 and then slowly move
yes
it said she didn't go for that what she
did is whoops that wasn't what I wanted
to do and she's moved her King all the
way up the board and currently reached
this position I believe
and at this moment I'm sure that
Jennifer is looking at the consequences
of Brook check
so the idea is that she wants to advance
her Pawn up the board
but the Rook is uh Anna's Rock on the
a-files made it difficult now if you
look at this this is not that easy
suddenly after a move like check the
Rook comes down and thanks to the
favorable position of the king I'm going
to say this is a three result game this
is not the extra fun that you want so
after this move Rook A5 King to B3 Rook
A1 I think you have to go all the way
back
as before all the way back to A8 and
then back to winning the Big King uh
Tata wow what a turnaround we saw Arena
was in the driver's seat most of this
game now it's taught to have as a equal
materials even but her phones are really
Advanced phones right exactly something
like Rook takes Rook takes and wow
it happened already no no this is just
my analysis it's just pretty obvious
that white is the uh one way ahead in
any races
um and what do you have uh for us uh
Christian well I was looking at the open
section and this big game between Sam
Savion and elshon moradia body Sam has
been piling on the pressure since the
Early Middle game but it did feel like
he allowed moradia body back into the
game and in fact at this particular
point after the move f 5. all moradia
buddy had to do was to give a check look
to A1 King to G2 continue with checking
Rook to G1 this is not easy because it
does feel like the King on H1 is a
liability for white nevertheless once
you get the king to F3 now F takes G6
and this is very difficult to understand
from afar is no longer a threat so what
I can do as black I can just simply pick
up the pawn on G5 if you do take on G6 I
give you a check now with the King on F3
I give you the check I take on F7 I
exchange the Rooks and that's an easy
draw that's easy but what if I go to H3
right King to H3 well you cannot take on
G5 because F takes G6 that's a mate and
this is what he was always afraid of
this move Rook to H7 and trapping the
king in the corner you cannot go Rook to
G8 because I just give you a check
anywhere on the board follow it up with
G7 on Rook to H7 and that's just game
over so big moment and big Miss by
elshon who actually played the move Rook
to F2 the problem is after the simple
Rook to A7 how do you stop me from
getting a pawn to G6 right and once I
get the pawn to G6 there's a one move
Checkmate threat with Rook to H7 that
you cannot Parry the only thing you can
do is actually take on F5
I go G6 and now you have to sacrifice
the bishop which to my eyes is not
looking great king to F3 Rook takes G6 I
have the move Bishop to F7 I'm not going
to take on E3 first because you take
with a check but I do go Bishop to F7
I'm not taking by the way the pawn on F5
because after root to F6 you don't have
time to capture the bishop only 3
without losing the bishop on F5 so you
have to put the bishop on a square that
is protected by The Rook follow it up
with King taste C3 I don't see a good
way to get to my Pawn to my H Pawn
without allowing my king to get on F6
and create the checkmating pattern that
white so Desires in the position and to
my eyes this is just a losing end game
for black so a big big moment missed by
Bon radiabadian all his efforts for the
last three four hours try to save this
game in a very unpleasant position might
go to waste a quick question for your
question in that variation that you have
on your board yes Rook to G7 King takes
E3 correct a king H7 of course now I
want to use my a pawn as a decoy China
for H5 of course King takes F5
threatening Bishop G6 King H6 uh King F6
of course just that's my Bishop yeah and
that's actually a nice situation and
Arena made a draw when we just came back
from our break we thought that Tata
wasn't it I wouldn't say that's the fair
result because Irena was much better
nevertheless you have to take your
opportunities guys when they're
presented to you you should take your
opportunities especially when you have a
better position against the a-time
national champion Irina Crush right one
of the toughest competitor in this field
you have a golden opportunity as white
to put some pressure it's not easy even
in this position they repeated the moves
by the way this is how it finished after
Knight to D5 Rook to Da Knight to C3
Rook to C8 and so on and so forth Rook
day C4 seems to have given white the
advantage how big of an advantage not
very clear look to B4 I can go King to
E7 once you go B6 I'm going to drop back
to d8 and stop your Pawn but what you
can do is try to use all your forces go
talking to be talking to b3c4 and it
does feel at least from a practical
perspective that white is better for
example you cannot easily approach the
pawn for example if you want to go King
to D6 to try to get to C5 that would be
an ideal square right unfortunately
after King D6 B6 there's no way to stop
the pawn so you have to put your pieces
on a passive Square first with Rook to
d8 and then I can just go King to B3
follow it up with Rook to E4 push my
pawns it just feels like you're faster
right you already have a Pawn on B5
supportive
by the route you cannot lose exactly
that's a very good point Anastasia you
cannot lose you have to take your
chances you have to continue putting
pressure on your opponent she did not do
that she accept it and by the way let's
take a look at how much time did they
have at this point
26 minutes for Irina only nine minutes
for Tate so perhaps
her time management started to pile up
additional pressure that she did not
like and decided to call it a day
uh missed opportunity for sure again I'm
looking at the game between Anna and
Jennifer the soul remaining game in this
round one of the US ladies
um
extra Pawn for Jennifer but seriously
for the last I'm going to say 15 odd
moves she has made no progress of the
progress the pond remains on A7 and uh
Anna's just waiting for her to come up
with something and in the meanwhile
maybe on a good day you get the pawn to
H5 and you start to feel like okay I can
expand and maybe make upon a
breakthrough
Jennifer hasn't found the right yes
blend yes I think that's a problem but I
think it's always an issue you know this
Rook endings like to tell you the truth
it's always it was always not the
easiest part for anyone right no exactly
like I know that once I asked this
question some top players will not
mention the names like 500 plus women
players and they ask about the Organics
goals at least do you know the Rook
endings and they said all of them that
they still suffer in life is not so easy
look no no I I I'm suffering So what had
happened to me this is about let's say
two two decades ago I have visited
Victor korchnoy in his home
in Switzerland and uh Victor what have
you been doing
he says well I've got this position on
the board it was four versus four in a
past one
and he says I don't know if it's a draw
or a win for white just an extra Pawn
and he said please you know teach me so
I sat down and he won it he won it he
won it he won it as white and then he
says well well now now you win it draw
draw as white and it was like he had
spent three months on one position in a
broken pot and you know he was writing a
book on rook and pot endings
they are difficult with a double
exclamation like I'm a candidate
Master like I'm playing in the
candidates and these Rook endings are
difficult uh this one if you didn't know
it from Jennifer's point of view putting
the King on A8 it's so that you can play
Rook D6 and A6 and then slowly make a
progress that's not natural it's not
easy it's not easy your natural
inclination is you want to put your King
on B4 and you want to play A5 and
support the pawn the problem is whenever
you put your kingdom before I'm going to
disturb it with this move Rook B1 check
and Jennifer spinning her Wheels like
how am I supposed to win this and it's
not easy it really really isn't the
crazy part uh Anastasia about endings no
I mean it's not a joke but at least half
at least half maybe 55 percent of all
endings are going to be Rook endings
learn them as best you can yes I know I
mean normally use you start with the
book books of other book also
how about you Christian how do you how
do you get your students at uh Colombia
and sit them down and pound actually The
Rook endings do a lot of uh
disproportionately amount of Rook end
games with them because I think they're
so important and they hate it of course
right everybody hates analyzing rook and
games and solving Rook end game puzzles
and uh they're so difficult it's not
only calculation right but it's
technique you have to give a shady check
here and there that doesn't look very
very clear so they're quite interesting
I have to say I like doing them as a
coach I hate solving them as a player
but you have to do it and you have to do
it as often as possible because you made
a great Point yes sir they come in and
and you end up in Rook end game compared
to other end games so much more often
exactly right so you have to drill those
Rook end games this is what we're seeing
this is an unusual one I have to say I
haven't seen this pattern in a very long
time how do we do it if you try to get
the king back to B7 into a the plan that
you are mentioning right after H4 I
think you just start with you did lose a
lot of tempees though right yeah well
it's but but from White's point of view
after okay uh Anna's just played the
move H4 if Jennifer starts with King B4
it's actually a pretty easy winning
threat the threat is to play A5 and
immediately put the Rook behind the a
pawn and you could just resign it's not
even close so Anna really doesn't have a
choice she has to give a check yes and
then after we step back once again we
have a very very concrete idea of
playing A5 so if we stop it and we play
King B6 and we stop A5 and we stop it
again now I want to play the move A6 in
King A7 bring my Rook to B7 and Rook to
B5 and A5 so we get you all the way back
here
and then I go D6 Rook D6 and A6 so I
think she but this idea of drawing the
king all the way back from this
aggressive position on B3 and putting it
all the way back on A8 it's not natural
it's not natural but you can come to it
yes after because everything else is
frustrated yes
I just want to say one other thing that
makes it that much more complicated for
Jennifer is right back here is she has a
false path that's very attractive the
false path is to put the rook in front
the pawn
Antigo Rook A4 now your your next moves
are very easy you're going to play A5
you're going to move the Rook You're
Gonna Go A4 until you get to this
position in your mind's eye and you go
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
uh but white is ready to harvest the
whole King side here suddenly and keep
on becomes really dangerous exactly and
for all of these Reasons by the way uh
Jennifer has come up with a different
idea altogether she I'm just going to
refresh my board she's played E5
stopping the king probably yes stopping
the king
but well
I'm not so sure I'm a fan of this it
makes it makes a potential weakness so
for example if Anna was to play G3 and
play for F4 like let me just put some
moves on the board for just a moment
these are not good moves for either side
you can see that suddenly this Pawn on
E5 might become a potential Target not
saying it's it's a terrible move or
something like that that's not going to
be the case E5 is reasonable but uh
maybe not the best technique
jumping to the open section the two
remaining games how is Jeffrey doing
with this I was about to say with the
alachine gun no nothing is extra pump
just what what to say extra Pawn uh
Jeffrey for uh choice but is this enough
is it enough
Knight C3 then I see 3 Knight C7 and how
do you break yeah Knight C3 Knight C7 of
course I'm going to take that Bishop oh
I think it's actually
first
[Laughter]
I actually think I do want to take that
but then that's fine King E6 let's see
how long do you continue
to take with the Knight I'll give you
everything you want I just want to see
if you've managed to break after uh well
it's gonna be long-winded we don't have
to go through all the variations but of
course I'm going to put the bishop on E2
and I'm going to bring my king as fast
as I can to the A4 Square to try to get
in the break B5 now your king may end up
on A6 my king may end up on A4 and then
when all of that is said and done I'm
going to go for F3 and in that case let
me ask a different question yes I'm
going to take with the pawn on B5 ah
that is what I was I was afraid of
actually
because at the end of the game the end
of the day in this variation this bishop
he's like
it's probably one of the most septic
looking pieces you're ever going to see
so you have to try something on the king
side right with Bishop D1 followed by F3
things of that nature but
where is the next break so you get F3
you take on e4 if I take with the F Pawn
you get G4 as well right
is that enough I don't know no is that
still enough so I'm waiting for you
everything right
now uh F3 and I'm waiting I don't know
maybe you can take even on F3 no and how
you will break through points should be
a very good point yes Anastasia
you're making it really really hard for
white to make a purpose here I like your
move seriously he takes F3 and then the
then the square E4 is fully protected
twice and this looks draw difficult to
break through learning from the best
but I like being a partner I should
mention that uh going to the game of Sam
they've gone right down that
that pathway that you were saying and
you were saying it's not easy for for
elshon to go after the H2 Pawn no played
the whole variation but even if you get
to the Aged upon the problem is once you
take it my king invades and if my king
invades and gets closer to the F6 Square
then you're in trouble funny you should
mention that because he's going there
guess what straight towards F6 and by
the way I think we're seeing signatures
I think this is over probably thinking
well it's the Checkmate yeah you can't
do F6 you control H7 with the bishop and
that's it you give a check on the f file
I cover with [ __ ] by five the game is
over
Bingo yes well played by nicely played
wow so Sam joins uh Hans Neiman as uh as
scope leaders yes maybe Jeffrey maybe
not but uh well done Sam that was uh
that was a very very awkward day like a
puzzle type of a game right you have to
find this so This Checkmate ideas and
put pressure on your opponents right it
was a but this was the crucial moment as
pointed out by Christian that this is
where elshon this is where chess is so
cruel Alshon has been defending
defending defending for all of these
hours and with the draw just in his
grasp right here he could have played
Bishop takes with the idea that he's got
the skier that results in a trade of
Rooks and it easily drawn ending
thereafter and the best thing you can do
maybe by the way speaking of G6 yes King
F2 sorry yes sorry Christian sorry yeah
yeah at that point and maybe this is
what he missed and once again Anastasia
is making a very good point so he can he
can read my thoughts
foreign
but you're not gonna get anywhere to F4
is coming maybe this is what he missed
you know before also at the end of the
line yeah because in your mind's eye if
you think for a moment that your Rook
has to give up then it's very easy to
see that the testimon is going to make a
a decisive breakthrough but let's take a
look at our current standings uh with
just a few get one game in each event
yes so remained right so we have Jeffrey
song still trying to win against Darius
sweet
players and attack the first yes and in
the ladies in the ladies section I think
we have also one Jennifer Jennifer is
trying to join Alice Lee that is a well
as
Megan oh my goodness and we didn't see
how Megan defeated Rochelle ah because
remember that was the two Bishops we
thought Rochelle stood better and a
bigger one of a lovely game against
Sophia yeah I think all the games are
over what why we have all the results no
because we don't have one game Jennifer
is still yes
I didn't see this game oh wait a minute
let me see how Megan a fellow
Washingtonian I mean I have to respect
that
this is where we thought that uh black
was for choice just the two Bishops and
then somehow she tricked herself
the queen side majority
kept
going
okay so that's the exchange sacrifice I
remember it now that we we got here and
again this reminded me of um the ending
between Fabi
and Hans uh
where Fabi won against the Bishops oh
look at that final move the bishop just
got trapped yes no no no squares oh
Beautiful Finish wow uh we didn't give
Megan the love there uh that was a very
important victory for her again Anna
versus Jennifer what do the engines by
the way uh say about this do they
realize that the king should go to A8 uh
most likely that is the way to make some
progress in the position after E5 though
since that G4 was in fact the better
move in the position try to potentially
go F4 later on in the game and break and
exchange as many pawns as you can right
because if you manage to exchange enough
pawns then you're going to be able to
sacrifice at the right time The Rook for
the a pawn and manage to get a pass Pawn
on the king side this is the drawing
plan for white in the position
unfortunately she played the move H5 and
it does seem like as black I'm going to
be able to stop you from all of that
right now let's continue Rook King to B4
Chuck King to C5 check King to B6 check
King B7 check
King A8 Rook to A1 right
Rook to D6 or Rook to B7 how do you want
to start I can also go Rook to B7 and
start looking at ideas of giving you a
check and kicking the king back maybe
that's a good idea by far the most
sensible to my mind yeah why though I
actually kind of like Rook to B7 this
comes out with a clear plan I kick your
king back but I also make space for my
king to go to B7 and actually support
the push of the pawn with the king
without being interrupted by checks on
the B file right okay and that's why you
put the Rook on B7 so how is this
position maybe after B7 King to D3 try
to whenever you give a check go to C4
create your own counter chances right
Rook to B2 and now we start counting
who's going to be first we don't want
that as black we want to keep things
controlled how do we do that let's go
Rook to B4
attack the pawn on e4 keep the king more
or less in check and right now King to
B7 is coming so once again white has to
find a path for uh some sort of
complications in the position Rook to A5
F6 defend upon on E5 and now you have to
go to D5 and try to give checks pick up
some pawns it gets dicey in the position
and even the engines are not really sure
whether white is going to be in time
with his counter play on the king side
but definitely this one is not going to
be an easy conversion for Jennifer you
and
I don't even know if she sees it but
perhaps she does because after age five
she did play King to B4 Rook to B1 and
now King is on C5 so she's headed
towards A8 the only way to make any
progress at this point and again A5
being such a powerful threat is obliged
to play Rook C1 and harass uh Black's
King back into the corner
exactly Rook C1 check on the board I
mean anticipating King
to B6 by the way did the engine like the
move E6 E5 I wasn't a fan of the move E5
no
not at all actually yeah just uh E5
allowed for this move G4 which was very
powerful and then I will be able to hook
that pawn I'm closer to that point to
exchanging that one after the move F4 uh
I believe this is why the engines were
not in support of this movie five I see
all right we'll keep our eye on that one
as we flash back to the game between uh
Jeffrey and darouche Bishop C4 saying I
don't even want you to take that uh
Bishop but again it's the fact that this
bishop on A3 is so so
powerless I mean you know you would be
begging to play the new B4 B3 so your
Bishop could go to B4 and activate
itself through the A5 square but with
this bishop on A3 the ninth coming to B5
maybe just recapturing with the pawn and
I don't see any way that Jeff Jeffrey uh
could break through looks to me at in
the uh
video that I'm seeing from the playing
Hall Jeffrey's like uh okay I don't see
how I'm breaking through on this one you
know oh yes sir it came to my mind that
if we exchange show pieces and keep only
the dark Square Bishops on the board
then I mean we come to this theoretical
position when you know all the pawns are
fixed like that and even black can throw
his Bishop like playing maybe bishop D5
right saying okay take my Bishop but
still draw like you cannot improve the
position exactly it's a typical position
to show to students actually that Bishop
which is blocked is not really active is
not an advantage even even if you have
an extra Bishop sometimes it doesn't
help at all exactly so okay just for fun
I remember uh well not remember there
was this uh famous story where uh the
bishop got really blocked just as you
said and the player was a pawn down
offered his opponent to draw
like I said I will think about it he
says what's there to think about even if
I remove my Bishop
you can't break through it's still a
drop okay that's a good point
Christian do you see any chances here no
I don't no there are there there's no
chances and actually this move Knight to
B5 kind of puts the kibosh on it because
it does force at least one trade right
you have to take on B5 with something
what are you going to take with if you
do take with a knight I take back with
the bishop and there's no way to remove
that Bishop from B5 whenever you go F3 I
take on F3 and we do exactly what
Anastasia predicted you're never going
to be able to break so now we might
actually just see an easy draw Knight
takes B5 was played on the board we
expect Bishop to B5
Bishop
takes B5
and I don't think you can make any
progress there you have a beautiful C
Pawn
but what do you do with it exactly this
bishop is the it's terrifyingly bad and
in fact right now even when you go F3
I'm not even looking at that pawn now
already no not anymore I'm not looking
at that pawn anymore really I don't
think so like you wouldn't I would be
taking this Pawn like in a Nanos but how
do you make any progress if I don't
uh that's fine go King D7 King C6
King D7 King C6
yes hold on can don't you give me a
window of opportunity here to play for
G4 that's fine you get G4
I'll let you get get G4 and I'm not even
going to take your Pawn on H4
no but yeah
to play G4 I will pick one of three with
check so you have to move maybe first
you will do this no no no no no no I
take with with the F Pawn even though I
can take with the E Pawn actually I
cannot because you go D5 right yeah you
go G4 keep going well I stay King C6 you
stay yes
can't I
walk my king eventually first the bishop
and then the king G5 I think you gave me
too much here did I give you too much I
think so Chris I mean I know you're a
generous person I might have given you
too much okay but I I
yeah but I was afraid that if you did
take on F3 again just maybe I have to do
it yes and you you right here uh what
honest Asia is saying you take on F3
you're never getting oops excuse me
you're never getting an E4 or G4 anymore
and here you got what you wanted which
is your Fortress correct yeah yeah
Christian decided to check like what you
will do in if you were passive let's say
you give me I wanted to give you
everything yes and see if that's maybe a
win or something so Jeffrey still will
try probably and check if uh his
opponent will find the best reaction at
this moment yes exactly and let me just
go back to Jennifer for just a second
because uh again uh I've got skin in the
game here I mean Jennifer was my pick so
uh let's see what we've got
as we'll bring up the game no this let
me just do a
a how do you say
yes a refresh
King D6 he didn't
come back to the corner now she might be
thinking okay I'm gonna be going
King E6 and I don't know I think
Jennifer
understandably you know is not glommed
onto the fact that the King on A8 is the
best way of yes it's awkward heart to
okay and Christian back to you as we
have guest in studio we are indeed with
Sam Savion who got a tremendous Victory
under his boat Sam first of all take us
through the game all right
um well he surprised me in the opening
with this rare line with Bishop before
checking A5 I think I played relatively
well with Bishop G5
although there are many ways to get a
slight Advantage here of Bishop E7
yeah this is a critical one because I
have many ideas I can take this Knight
on F6 and play Knight C3
uh which either he has to play Passive
position with D6 or play D5 which is not
really an ideal
qgt structure maybe this is how I
actually have to play yeah id5 yeah I
think I should have played like this
because uh I played Queen C2 yes and he
played interesting with Knight A6
with the idea of Knight before or C5
somewhere
I'm pretty sure this is wrong with the
special takes up six Knight G5 but
uh
maybe A3 first and after C5 I should do
it
take on F6 now Bishop takes F6 yeah
because now I can take his net and A6 at
the end which is very important yes yes
take okay seven take take and D5 I think
yeah now this is very nice because he
doesn't get benoni now with Ed B5
because opponent C5 is hanging very
important I have D6 have A4 and you go
A4 right beautiful position for weight
um very nice instead I went for this
immediately and the drawback was that I
loved night before
after Bishop takes B7
yeah now there's no more nights no no I
can't capture the net yeah C5 still it
feels like you so it should be better
advantage in the position
the five Bishop F6 maybe bishop F6 is a
mistake I think you should play etxc
first and after C takes D now he gets a
banana 66p5
D6 and B5 right yeah
what if uh what if you try not to laugh
I can't try this yes no he's not on
before
um
I'm actually curious can you play B5
instead of D6 perhaps yeah that's a good
point
B5 and what if you try to go this yes
now I can try to go this is very
interesting or A4 first is also
interesting
after B5
A4 first yeah
these things just feels visual I guess
to try to avoid depend on only
structures uh and if you take now D6 is
that the point or
I'm not sure it's a very complicated
position here but it still feels like
you're harboring some hopes or an
advantage I think that's a little better
here at this point okay loves this
Knight 65 idea and if he takes on B2
which is
uh let's say Rook B1 Bishop goes back I
go E3 and now it's now the move A5 is
really bad because the opponent B6 is
extremely weak I can play along the D
file attack the d-pawn zero Pawn down
but actually you're better you're much
better yeah because I have a risk-free
attack on the king side whenever I want
to start yeah I think it's objective
maybe winning here close to winning yeah
wow
and he played this move B5 let's
reactivate his this was correct yeah but
I think I played perfectly rookie one
and queen C2
to C3 he was really trying to give the
pawn back yeah
27. uh maybe yeah I'm not super
really no I think you played well I I
think you definitely there's one where
I'm not sure about my yeah this is fine
I like Queen A4 yes yeah Bishop Rook D3
maybe here
right so what the engine was saying is
that you have to take advantage and
capture the B file the control of the B
file
Queen B3 and then Rook to B1 yeah this
is nice yeah yeah definitely and now you
have everything once I get the people
it's pretty much over yeah go Bishop D5
C4 Queen B7 if you want
and just to interrupt you for a second
Jeffrey's game did finish with a draw
against Darius zverch
nothing unexpected in that one let's
continue with the analysis Sam so I
played Rook D3 and after G6 now I just
now notice that I can attack this go
move along the B file but now it's a bit
shakier because what happened in the
game so I tried Bishop key also another
reason this is probably worse is because
I allowed H5 H4 ideas and he was also
playing Super Quick at this point I
think he's trying to put some pressure
on it I think he was trying to play
against the clock yeah did you feel any
pressure building up at this point or
did you feel the position is simple
enough for you rookie three definitely
it feels impressive if I had some time
extra time I would probably find queen
queen yeah now yeah this is a very nice
idea for him
Rook design Rook B2 I really don't know
how to play here I checked like
everything King F1 Bishop D5 Bishop E6
um
maybe I should go take the policy six
but yeah also he didn't have that much
time to check out right right yeah only
eight minutes at this point you spend
six of them on this movie I I realized
that I can always get tunes with Rook
Cafe Rook of stone which is nice
yes very nice I did this a few times
gained some time
I think here he kind of panicked with
Bishop E1 this is also a draw but H6 was
much safer in my opinion because F4
let's say A4
F5 captures captures A3
and now I can't go F6 because Bishop
takes F6 Rook takes in Rook B2 let's see
and Tiana is going
you cannot you're not in time to defend
I do have a fight you'll see that but
Bishop he just stays here yes yes no way
to make progress I guess
very nice so he chose Bishop B1 he
didn't see F4 idea
I think this was a cute idea if you go
G5 just recruit
it's again this with C4 that ruined it
and uh he's just running
um and he played Rook to f8 of course he
saw that you gave another check F4
gained a couple of tempies I think
everything he did correct here yes just
he didn't see the
is H5
H5 here H5 is awesome H4 Rook F2
this might be okay too yes based on the
same idea with Rooker yes okay
and actually uh at this point he had
another opportunity
after um F5 yes he must play G1 check
uh I think what he missed was King F3
Bishop G5 King F2 and he has Rook G4
here okay yeah yeah this is why we
thought that he missed as well probably
did you speak with him after the game
yeah yeah he did miss this and after
that after you pick up uh but his main
Miss was in the game that I Bishop F7 at
the end of the line yeah yeah yeah
Bishop to F7 because the point is Rook
F2 doesn't actually threaten anything
which is nice I just moved my Rook away
and there's no Rook F1 check anymore
yeah
very nice game Sam congratulations you
start off the US Championship with the
bang how do you feel about your chance
is what is your motivation in this event
uh well I had a really good event last
year and I'm definitely trying to build
on that especially with two extra rounds
uh there are more chances for decisive
results so do you feel that helps you
the extra two rounds because of your age
let's say I think so I mean we'll see
how it goes at the end but I'm happy
that there are many runs in this
tournament absolutely more rounds more
chess congratulations Sam and we'll see
you tomorrow thank you uh Sam a question
for you if you don't mind as a
competitor in the US Championship are
you annoyed that uh events uh the
cheating scandals or overshadowing the
tournament you're not just concentrating
and focused on
the beautiful national championships
that we have I mean I'm never annoyed by
these things in general it's happened
before an open tournament and I just
kind of block it out and concentrate on
the chest fair enough a great answer
thank you Sam and good luck in the rest
of the tournament thank you absolutely
and there was one one game remaining
Anastasia and the ladies are fighting it
out still
we have this position on the board
well again I'm I'm seeing uh progress
right now
yes exactly Rook check I'm expecting the
king will finally uh be crawling into
the corner and actually and The Rook is
already on the B file yeah she's done it
in a nice way so that the Rook can come
for example sorry after Rook A1 in order
to stop A5 and Rook A7 after we we're
now in a very nice way uh that we get to
go King B7 and you know slowly slowly
like the tortoise uh keep making
progress up the board with King B6 and
A5 looks very very good for Jennifer can
we try to create something like Rook A5
Rook D5 after everything you show right
here yes
D5 I don't know what I'm trying no no no
I'm absolutely right no to eat something
hungry exactly no you're absolutely
right you have to create such counter
chances as these I suppose
right yes so that I I definitely do want
to well in that case I'm not putting I
think you have to start with Rook C5 so
King B8 let's go for it Rook C5 uh how
do you mean immediately if you put as
much pressure on the structure as soon
as possible ah Rook C5 here yes I think
this is what she wants and we have six
and F4 F4 ah your idea yes
I just need to create something
I agree wholeheartedly with that maybe
it's enough control play for under now
and she needs to do it fast because
Jennifer also is down to her last minute
and a half that's not a lot of time
and again in this uh there there's two
time controls uh 40 moves uh first 90
minutes then 30 minutes for the second
and no extra time and now they'll be
playing on increments and I have to say
The Rook on C5 also it attacks the pawn
on E5 but also defense against you
pushing quickly with the a pawn right
you cannot go A5 it does exactly the
same job as The Rook on A1 right so
let's put it on a more active Square I
agree wholeheartedly and I'm I if I was
in Jennifer's shoes I would be playing
the move Rook E7 in order to recapture
any F takes with Rook takes E5 I suppose
King F3 King G4
let's try it out am I in time the
question is exactly well uh again it's
all about motoring the a pawn up the
board right you know what the problem is
what's that
once you put the Rook behind the pawn
that Rook on the seventh rank protects
that G7 square that G7 pawn and any time
you get to that G6 square with the King
you're not threatening anything
there's no threat in the position that's
a big problem maybe I can even start by
taking on F4 right
yeah in fact that's a very good point
the moment I lose contact with the front
on e4 so for example King B7 King G4 you
can take on e4 immediately threatening
Rook takes so you have to take back
thinking and by the way Rook to A1 was
played Anna said Rook on C5 a bit too
active for my taste and also
there's this problem that we just saw
right and maybe she was right about it
yes yeah maybe she wants black to play
first through B6 for example and then
maybe only a row K5 or well this move
Rook eb3 check especially is really
irritating because the King has to go
back back
and maybe after for example King E2 Rook
to B5 is now very strong wow the idea is
any F4 could be met by you know a shadow
attack x-ray if you will on the eighth
Pawn in the meantime if you do I don't
know something like this
now I get A5 and my king will come up
and again slowly slowly like the
tortoise
excuse me after Rook B5 Rook B5 yeah
this little quiet moves uh to to to
slowly slowly Advance right repeat one
let's say King A7 ah thank you yes and
once again I'm trying to set up with my
Rook on the seventh yes
again these very very torturous uh Rook
component games that you have to learn
torture is the word I wanted to use many
times
and you said this finally exactly
um I must say that for myself uh Rook
endings played a very important part and
and I
that that book by uh smeslaf and
overbach on those Rook endings oh that
that whole group of books I mean that's
what propelled me I think to the master
class I never paid that much attention
to endings until I became a strong class
player like b and a player then I
started saying aha it's not just about
openings or tactics who said that you
should study chess from findings I think
it was nimsovich actually he was the
first but uh not the last uh definitely
if you learn your endings Kappa yeah
learn your learn your endings uh
the the and a friend Michael frenette
Mike frenette from Washington State said
yeah sir learn your endings it's like
cheating on an exam really I go what
he's like cheating because you're gonna
get these positions in your games so
learn your end Games first
cheating yes
many times Washington state champion he
he proved is what uh words uh
prophetically good advice and I have to
say uh they're also Pleasant to actually
learn because there's my new details in
simple positions that just create the
game and make the whole difference in
the position and in the assessment of
the position so it's definitely
um pleasing let's say whenever you find
those like little checks to get the king
a little bit further away from the
action and then go back to whatever you
were doing before those are the type of
details that you have to learn in order
to progress in chess and make it to the
National Master feed the master
International Master Grand Master Level
this is how you should progress in chess
focus on your end games guys
uh I've always used this model in my
advice for players is if you want to
learn an opening
you want to learn to play the night or
well and VL he's your guide you know you
want to learn the groom felt well
Christian he's your guy no no sorry no
no sorry
I meant Peter Peter wrong notes wrong
notes wrong commentator do you have an
ending guide that you recommend uh
Christian well Carson Mueller was one of
the guys that I was following in his
books of end games as well as uh the
voretsky and gay manual I think that was
a big one and probably that was my
Generations uh end game of pokken maybe
the
before Generation as well what was your
Generations
I I don't know what but yes sir but I
mean let's say also we studied other
Bach books and we're at school later but
I can still mention the book yesterday
you wrote I use it also for my students
simple and games but this is something
to start with definitely I mean you you
always explain it in a very easy way and
it's I think very important yeah but to
have the very clear ideas for for me it
was uh Reuben fine uh the end game by
ideas I think boy I got it boy I studied
that book so much I wanted to kick drop
it down the stairs uh it turns out that
there were many many mistakes like
really in the Moment In the book and so
they would make this a Rada of you know
the Reuben fight end games except in
this you got like the errat has started
getting as big as the book it was like
very very frustrating as I was learning
these endings but yes I was raised on
Reuben fein's basic chess endings that
was the name of the book by the way F7
F6 right here this is where I was
thinking or at least recommending Rook
to B5 threatening to play F5 threatening
King B7 Jennifer started with King
and Rook A5 F6
Kingston 6 Maybe
something what we discussed yes and if I
go back then rugby seven
yes Rook B7 and also just a second
did it make a difference that our King
is on B6
like I mean there's going to be a moment
when this Pawn is actually flying down
the board and the capture of the G7 Pawn
isn't going to be of a consequence yeah
also remember when Anna had eight
minutes and journey for two minutes yes
Jennifer still has two minutes Anna has
one minute and 30 seconds
because finally she found the plan and
it's really hard for Rana to defend this
position she understands What's
Happening Now absolutely you have to go
Rook D5 you have to yes you have to go
Rook D5 and pray
that's great
the problem is Rook D5 I can also go
King C6 right
maybe even King C7
yes 25 finally on the board one of the
uh I was the uh captain for the ladies
team in Baku it was really a marvelous
Olympiad and one of the things that I
really discovered is what a great
fighter Ana zutanski was I mean she was
definitely our All-Star it was really
really a shame at the very end she was
undefeated she lost the last game
against India
to Tanya but boy
I mean at the board she she sits and
ferociously defends the most difficult
positions Rook d8 I know first since
1995 believe it or not yesterday where
from Ukrainian like she was always
considered to be like one of the best
players in Ukraine at that time exactly
and she was always a fighter and a good
example for every uh girl you know the
way yeah she was inspiring of course
yeah and very talented to learn time a
long time ago yeah
I remember I had played her once in a
rapid chest tournament that we were set
up and
it was like the pairings were just up
and I was just getting seated and
waiting for the others to she says let's
go like let's start I was like let's get
it over with you
please take it easy let's go uh Rook d8
but Rook B7 is really begging to be
played because it threatens Rook D7
check and that's going to be awkward for
maybe and this is what I thought what
I'm saying when I'm uh mentioning those
little checks why don't we start with
Rook to B2 get the king a little bit
closer to the other side
because you have to defend the pawn on
F2 I think right and then go Rook B7 so
you're pushing the king away from the a
pawn yes the action is on the a file
right you will try to catch that a pawn
with your king
kick your king away a little bit more
Rook to B7 yeah the reason I was
actually attracted to the move that
Jennifer chose
Rook to B7 was just hey I've got this
humongous threat of a rook D7 check
forcing the trade and if you step out of
the uh to check you know like a dream
come true at long last but is it though
I get to play A5 and now I go Rook A8
yeah
and now King B3 yeah oh God that's okay
and now I go Rook C8 and then I go A4
check
right and King A3
King try to say that once I got my king
on the eighth by the way she has
followed your advice and put her King on
C3 let me just refresh I'm not saying
I'm gonna survive this no no no no it's
it's all these positions are all about
making your opponent's task or as
difficult as possible and forcing them
to and if they find all the right move
well power to them but at least not to
make it easy and maybe you're right uh
generation pushing the king to E3 might
be one of those subtleties that Jennifer
will regret and getting down to the last
30 seconds right away something to be
said I played A5 just because I'm
Dreaming for the last 30 movies
but uh maybe something to be said for
Rook D7 as well and okay Jennifer
also dreamed about it yes she's been
dreaming A5 on the board
is that the move 60 new score sheets
yeah so now I don't know what what is
the best chance with I think the the one
the Christian show I like this idea of
of blocking with the king so you have to
start with Rook A8 so that the king can
cross the B file and get in front of the
a pawn if you
I mean if you wait too long I still go
A4 yeah yeah eight four Rook B3 check uh
could really uh hurt your feelings there
I think she has to go rookie
yes so Rook A8
now we went King B6 uh again with the
straightforward idea anything to be said
for King B5 yeah I'll do the same thing
still drop
in front of there so I don't see why
Rook A8 King B6
King B3 15 seconds for Anna oops to make
a move she has to make a decision seven
seconds ten oh my God oh my God four
four okay okay that's a big surprise
push even further down the board with F
four I don't like this move I don't know
either I don't like this decision yeah
the problem I see is that any Rook B3
check means instantly this Pawn on G3
gets lost and it's game over precisely
A4 looks like Jennifer now has again you
know you're trying to make it as
difficult for your opponent to win as
possible but the loss of the G3 Pawn is
just that's it your two pawns down and
you no chance
okay Anna is going to be relieved with
that decision because that just took
one potential weakness and that was a
big maybe not only the other guys but
maybe I can go E5 at the right moment
and create a create a passer of your own
Jennifer must have had Rook B5 is her
idea what do you think about that
[Music]
E7
ah so her idea is if you play King D4
I've got that nice Rook Rook uh trade
waiting how are you going to defend this
is it really working oh yes it should be
yes so perhaps I have to start with Rook
GA right
Rook G8
the more pawns we exchange the better is
for me as white at this point
but
a for Christian A4 King B4 well then I
take a check
okay let's keep going
no no A14 B4 I I what even this no King
A3 no take on F4 I take on G7 ah you go
back
you're a tricky guy all right all right
uh you started before I'm preventing
move A4 actually that's the idea rookie
seven and Rook if D4 she stops at the
pawn for the moment rookie seven so no
Rook G8 no uh you're trying to be
obstinate there for a moment there
Christian Rook to
d sub
then you have to play Rook C4 check then
King to B6
okay okay
that makes a lot of sense to my eyes
yeah but then can be three maybe A4 then
but A4 King A3 I'm not forced to take it
whoa
um nothing's wrong with this move Rook
A7 I was just wondering 57 might have
been a much more Awkward move for Anna
to meet uh what's the idea again it's
those little subtle nuances that after
again I'm threatening
these kinds of things none of that
happened we have Rook a
is on a relaxing spiritually right now
it does feel like she's much more
relaxed clock kind of doesn't look like
that 55 seconds for Anna and 12 seconds
and counting 10 seconds right now for
Jennifer
okay a for checking with me king is
three and now maybe King B5
yes King C5 that's a Tempo Against The
Rook she's she's looking to
play the move Rook E7
all right like if the Rook were to go to
d8 or say D1 not Rook D5 check Rook E7
is Jennifer's idea um
that looks like a very strong idea she's
ready to use her Apon as a decoy how
about this how about Rook to D1
Rook to E7
Rook to G1 King D4 I want you to
foreign
[Laughter]
I think the king is just simply too too
far away at this point but okay let me
just refresh my board apologies
everybody just refresh and we have King
C5 on the board
I hate to ask the obvious question but
the is are we in uh table-based
territory uh how many here uh I don't
think there is any table base right now
no there's too many pawns still left
still too many pawns yeah Rook B4 okay
that's a much better move than uh my
lousy Rook D1 rookie seven
that's a great move just just asking
questions where do you go like if
Brooklyn what's your next turn yeah that
is a great move
maybe just go back
oh
how to make a process exactly Jennifer's
asking yourself well one way to try to
make progress is to give up the pawn
with Rook D7 Rook D7 then for example
you take the pawn but you cannot take it
with the king that's the key because
yeah to play this move wow Rook D7 yeah
yes only with so don't take with the
King because that's what the reason for
is
end of story no okay so she will have to
take the Pawn With The Rook let's see
and then
well we have a check
and she's done it Rook takes A4 okay
Jennifer can also start with Rook D4 and
um
exactly I take on G7 you take on F4 I go
Rook G6 that's an easy draw that should
be an easy draw
yep I would agree with you
and I think Anna might have saved this
one wow
that's what we're saying about her
tenacity is just
it's too early to call but her chances
of surviving have increased
significantly right away Jennifer is
playing in some kind of a positional
fashion where she's saying look you're
piece down
agree your King on A3 is terrible so
let's go King A2 improve the piece
any Rook move will allow the king to go
to D4 and then on to a Harvest on the
king side so you can't move the Rook
can't move the Palms really well
maybe E5
she moved upon you think they give King
D5 for K5 check so right maybe an hour
okay five I know Ruby five
that's very important too you're in the
Square so if you take take and if you
recapture pardon me then the king is
right in time like this looks
this looks fabulous
going over here and just winning all the
pawns
um
the move again the move King A2 I think
was more challenging than
E5 I think E5 kind of helps Jennifer
yes
yes they made it now
right is that the plan you want to get
the Rook to G6 ASAP yes Rook G4 and Rook
G6 and kind of asking questions
like don't allow the king to get to F6
we know that right all right so at some
point okay you're going to have to give
you put a king on F4 let's say
to B5
let's put the king to F4
and since
well she's grabbed the pawn and Rook G6
Anna's uh looking at every Every Witch
kind of Fortress she can
to make again it very difficult for
opponent and now we should be in table
based yes it's a draw it's a draw it's a
draw it's a draw she saved it wow okay
but so you have to make it I mean what
about if you take h-pond King is quite
far away but yeah I mean are we on time
to bring the king
well the problem is King A4 I'm not
allowing it to go wrong yes it's
important move I think so you have to
lose a couple more times I think so I
keep the King on ah okay yes I like that
and now let's run and then we'll run
let's run then it's yeah yeah
no no let's run to C4 because I don't
want to allow you to go to Rook D5 thank
you very important Point uh
running to C4 so that you don't get your
your king cut yes
and something as few files as possible I
need to be caught
yes
and now what I do I'm going to go Rook
to G1 and I'm going to give you checks
from the front
sorry you're going to go yes and give me
checks
in front of my king
so that you're going to focus one now
look H1 first no no no okay sorry
aha so that okay first I I definitely
that's an annoying checkup
kick me out of class
okay King D3 let's go am I still in time
uh King d3d3 let's try to survive this
not so sure
I like how you take it personally now
you're really lucky yeah
he's so competitive I can see that right
okay and it's one of those things too we
have this wonderful passive aggression
yes so we say oh it must be a draw it
must be a draw well let me try
let's go Rook H4 am I still in time who
cares what's happening on the board
right now
and I guess I get Rook H1 let's go back
so your king is really really close I'm
I'm almost there almost
it's important but then you go King G2
and there's no more checks ah and I get
to kick you once oh you kick me again no
stop kick
by the way there are some absolutely
absolutely marvelous studies of these
Rook component games that uh thrilled Me
growing up King F3 so Jennifer's
thinking that one day she's going to
drop her Rook on the B1 Square
followed by Rook H1 trading the G7 Pawn
for the H5 Pawn but she's thinking that
her King
may be more ideal on F3 than the F4
Square
maybe such a really difficulty
is too uh very deep yeah and deep well
it's gonna go five seconds Anna no no
how much yes so it's a minute she has a
minute
ah sorry I didn't see the clock so well
wow okay so she needs to keep the king
there not to allow maybe to sometime
this rugby five as you said to win
couple of temples right exactly so again
we expect that this Rook is gonna have
to go
to H1
one day she isn't getting a chance to
play Rook to B5 and Rook takes H5 saving
a Tempo Okay so
let's go with it let's let's see how it
would play out let's try it again all
right yes I tried it once you somehow
got what you did last time no no no no
no yes or no no I didn't like it no well
you played King C4 so that the Rook
wasn't allowed that seems to be the
right direction for the moment Rook
E7 what's the idea okay the same idea
same ideas the king is
the king is gonna end up on C4 The Rook
is going to end up on in fact it's a
trickier idea because if you go King B4
now I have check and Rook G4 so that's a
nice little wrinkle oh you are so right
I Like It Go King B3 you have to go King
B3 by the way King B5 also loses because
of rookie 5 Rook G5
that's a very that's a very important
point right okay
this is this is the whole point Rook G5
resigns that's the end of story but
equally but what about rookie 3 now
maybe it's the same this also would be
resigned oh that's that is why King B3
sorry look look knocking this three
rookies three check where do you go it's
winning yes it's the same the same idea
lovely lovely what an idea by Young
Jennifer
what Anna had to do was actually hide
the King on the sixth rank no okay how
to how to get it how to guess that one
yes yes
wow and then rookie two wins and rookie
four what a turn of events guys wow
she did
she did and again these tricky Rook
endings right and we've been loading
Anna zatonski for her tenacity but
Jennifer equally so up to the task I
mean you cannot be U.S women Champion if
you are not like that right you never
need to be the one who is who fights
until the end
yeah so she plays Kingston Kingston same
idea like okay now we're looking for
checking D5 for example Rook G4 and that
was where we just stopped our analysis
completely and said anytime you're not
allowed to grab the pawn on G7 you're
going to lose the pawn on H5
and there's no way the Rook will be able
to save the pawn on H5
almost probably is yeah
really hard to hold by the way Rook 24
played with only seven seconds seven
seconds
I'm telling you Jennifer is a thrill
seeker we saw her do this during her run
by the way
shaking her head because she thinks that
after root to G4 King to E6 might be a
problem I just look at this king is six
no Rook takes takes each five we have
seven eight four king G7 H3 King F7 H2
and I'm in time
it's actually a draw no it's
unbelievable it's a draw guys this is
this is this is like a Shakespearean
okay
the only winning move right now is Rook
G5
of King
she's reaching for a rook is Jennifer oh
if she finds it if she finds Rook G5 and
King G4 oh that would be fabulous that
is so pretty it's very hard to find that
G5 she found it got it
oh what the game wow what a move
and I think for Anna that was also a
shock that was a cold shower I think you
could see it on her face I think she was
playing for this King E6 thinking that
she had a fortress Rook G5 King F7 King
G4 you take it he takes King takes and
it's embarrassing you don't have Rook H6
oh my goodness this is study like study
like game yes no that what a beautiful
ending yeah wow you you almost want to
clip this out and put it in your
um end game manual right that whole Rook
E3 r Rook E4 Rook G4 concept was very
nice always and so by the way
takes G5 King F7 we could check but then
again King G4 unbelievable King G4 oh
that's the simplest I I was still
thinking that we're going to make it yes
but the king G4 is perfect and King H4
yes we have to check this one as well
Anastasia that's just past is pretty
that's a brilliant game a brilliant end
game by Jennifer maybe she missed some
chances along the way but given the time
situation and given how she handled it
and after the exchange of these pawns
the A and the F Pawn wow just incredible
absolutely the last variation to check
again to take take and think of 5G fork
in G6 not in time not six years
is because I have the King on F3 and I'm
ready to go King G4 whenever you put the
King on h8 you go back to G7 and then I
sidestep I go King H5 and that's it
I'm in time yes
65 H takes G5 I'm expecting King F7 what
else okay this is what that will check
it was checking like before is the
position with the king so let's go King
F7 or King F5 it doesn't really matter
it's the same thing okay actually no
King F7 let's go King F7 she's played
King F5 she's played a king of 5G
why wouldn't you play King G3 King takes
G7 G2 but with the pawn only on H6 and
not on H7 it's actually a pretty simple
win now but I think even with the pawn
on age seven no come on with H7 it's a
draw is it yes how
yeah I think it's a draw
I think it's a draw my king cannot pass
to F7 yes
what a game guys
it was worse it was worth the wait I
mean uh definitely there's always in
these U.S championships uh one game that
goes let's say past the Midnight Hour
this one was amazing uh I think it
taught us a lot and so many lessons to
learn from this end game truly for
anybody that this end game from the
beginning there are so many things
by the way Queen check came immediately
but also the idea of King G4 and King G5
blocking so that you like Checkmate yes
yes like something like of this nature
right yes where you can
I I just putting this on right this is
uh okay but Queen D4 and this is it wow
this one is over beautiful no that was
beautiful but sometimes you just got to
tip your hat and say bravo bravo
yes sir congratulations I must admit
well funny you should say that uh but
that's only one round you've got a
marathon ahead of us yeah 13 Rounds uh
round robin 13 opponents
um I don't know if the ladies are going
to have the energy to come and say
something wonderful and insightful but
Christian sum up
our opening round I mean what an
incredible opening round and I have to
say a lot of interesting results uh Hans
winning with the black pieces linear
putting a lot of pressure I have to say
on Fabiano also with the black pieces
after Fabiano let's say employed a quite
a risky opening and allowed black to
have those two Bishops on the board that
potential attack via C4 D4 opening up
the diagonals that was a very shaky
first game for Fabiano but saved it
where the white piece is crucial safe
for Fabiano in in the lady section so
many interesting results as well beg him
winning with the white pieces Jennifer
what an incredible grind I mean this was
just a worthy game uh potentially game
of the tournament who knows what we're
going to see in the later rounds but
that end game King to F3 the perfect
placement for the king to have all of
those checks check on e4 check on E2
check on E3 as well to kick your king
away and I was looking through the lines
the way to equalize the position
actually to make a drawing that end game
was extremely difficult it was Out Of
Reach of a lot of super Grand masters
with that time situation on the clock
only a few seconds for Anna so
definitely Anna doesn't have anything to
beat herself about because that was such
a difficult one but Jennifer such a
fighter as well absolutely four decisive
games than ladies two decisive uh games
in the open we'll just take a look at
the current standings after one around
the play yeah
yes we have early co-leaders Sam Sevilla
and Hans Neiman they got full points the
the youths yes leading against uh wow
look at that chasing pack of players
Bobby Wesley Lanier Jeffrey Sam Ray
darush move on Alex and wonder and in
the ladies in the latest section yes we
also have this ready we have I think
four oh yes four girls I mean they are
living now so Becky Jennifer Ellis and
Megan all of them they won their games
today so they actually at the top maybe
Arena and Tata were both unhappy but
maybe they're both happy I don't know
because they certainly had their chances
as well and uh with that I think it's a
good time to say uh good night everyone
and we will see you all tomorrow thank
you for sharing your day with us thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited